Đây là cái giao diện của màn hình MTI
Dravity 2.0 dành cho những anh chị chưa
chưa dùng để mình hình dung ra cái giao
diện của nó tí xíu. [âm nhạc] Rồi đây là
giao diện của 2.0 và mình vẫn sử dụng
song song hai cái nền tảng [âm nhạc] vừa
anti Davity cũ là IDER này mọi người. Và
mình sử dụng song song luôn cái nền tảng
là Anti Dravity [âm nhạc] 2.0. Và cái cơ
chế của nó nó cho mình swit nha. Nó cho
mình chuyển đổi qua lại bình thường. Nếu
như mình đang thao tác với một cái
[âm nhạc] project rồi mình sẽ nói lại tí
xíu chỗ này thì ở đây nó cho mình chuyển
đổi qua [âm nhạc] lại với một cái nút
bấm ở trên này mọi người thấy không ạ?
Open ide thì lúc này bây giờ á họ họ
thấy rằng là cái việc là chuyển đổi mà
bỏ thì nó không đúng và có thể đó là
thời gian đầu họ mới tách ra thôi chứ
thực tế là họ không à không bỏ hãng đâu
và nó có sự liên kết với nhau nên mình
thấy cái chỗ này rất là hay nhé. mình có
thể swit qua lại giữa hai cái ứng dụng
với nhau. Trong trường hợp ví dụ như
mình đang hồi nãy mình đang nói về cái
multiagent thì trong cái sự kiện mà
Google [âm nhạc] AI á họ build ra một
cái hệnh
mini chỉ trong đâu đó trong tích tắc thì
chỉ với một cái câu lệnh thôi. Chỉ đúng
nghĩa là với một cái câu lệnh thì họ đã
build ra được một cái ứng dụng à hoàn
toàn
à gọi là chỉ trong tích tắc chỉ trong
với cái câu lệnh này team [âm nhạc]
work review. Như vậy thì mình hình dung
ra ở trong cái teamwork review này nó là
như thế nào ạ? Nó khác hẳn hoàn toàn với
bên cái nền tảng của Google Anti Gravity
[âm nhạc]
Ider cũ nhé. Nó sẽ không có cái chức
năng teamwork [âm nhạc] review à đây. Nó
không có cái câu lệnh đó mọi người ạ.
Mình bấm x flash vân vân các kiểu là nó
không có. Và trong các tài liệu mọi
người có thể resarch thêm trong các tài
liệu đây. Tài liệu góc của Google luôn
nha chứ không phải là do tự mình tự mình
ấy đâu. Đây tài liệu
anti 2.0 nè. Thì mọi người vào trong này
xem nó sẽ có cái phần là multiagent á.
Trong đây nó sẽ có một cái phần là
multiagent. Đại khái là [âm nhạc] như
vậy ha. thì mọi người sẽ nắm rõ hơn là
về cái
team [âm nhạc]
work review đó nó là một cái câu lệnh
mạnh nhất đến thời điểm này trong cái hệ
sinh thái của các câu lệnh của của
Anti 2.0
thì chỉ với một câu này thôi và mình yêu
cầu nó [âm nhạc] xây dựng ví dụ nhé xây
dựng một trang web à
bán hàng
à mỹ phẩm
Hàn Quốc
hình ảnh
dùng
nano
banana
tự sinh ví dụ vậy nhá mình đang nói là
dùng nano banana nano banana à nano
banaana [âm nhạc] rồi tự sinh rồi mình
ví dụ thôi để cho mọi người chỉ với một
câu này thì nó sẽ ra cái gì nhé
lúc này cái
cái cái câu lệnh này nhá nó tự động nó
sẽ build lại bill Buill lại đúng nghĩa
là nó sẽ build lại cái câu cơ bản của
mình thành một cái mega firm hay nói nôm
nay là anh xây dựng thành một cái
[âm nhạc] full nó gọi trong cái từ mà
những anh mà làm về dep á nó sẽ gọi là
build thành full stock full stock luôn
có nghĩa là đóng gói thành nguyên một
cái quy trình [âm nhạc] từ đầu đến đuôi
cần phải làm những gì những gì những gì
đây mọi người nhìn vào cái à cái cái gọi
là cái ROM RAP này là đang cái gọi là
cái bản tạm bản nháp bắt đầu nó sẽ đi
hỏi hỏi mình nè làm những [âm nhạc] gì
và bắt đầu nó sẽ đi thu thập những cái
này cho nó đầy đủ. Landing page
[âm nhạc] marketing, trang shop đầy đủ,
nhiều danh mục giỏ hàng vân vân ờ
catalog show trưng bày vân vân thì mình
sẽ chọn lại một cái ha tùy vào nhu cầu.
Rồi tối [âm nhạc] giảng sang trọng đắ
luxury. Rồi ví dụ như cái này skin scare
hay là makeup hay là cả hai. Rồi mình
chọn cả hai. Naro.
Ồ mình đây là mình đang đi nhanh để cho
mọi người hình dung được cái sức mạnh
của nó là mình để mọi người thấy thôi
nhé. [âm nhạc]
Aerobanner
danh sách sản phẩm review công dụng chi
tiết
ờ bạn t. Ok. tới này luôn đi. Tất cả
luôn đi.
Rồi thì dựa trên những cái thông tin mà
nó vừa thu thập mình vừa khai báo lại
cho nó vừa thu tập bắt đầu nó sẽ đi nó
build [âm nhạc] cái from này chi tiết
hơn ha. Cái nó sẽ tự động nó sinh ra cái
này. À đáng lý ra nãy mình sẽ có thể
chọn xong ngữ luôn nè.
Đó. Rồi tạo thương hiệu tên ngẫu nhiên
[âm nhạc] tự sinh.
Mình sử dụng né Netx đi. Cái này nó chạy
cũng khá là hay.
Xây dựng web thì bây [âm nhạc] giờ mình
sẽ sử dụng cái cái nền tảng là NetX này
nhiều nè.
Rồi bây giờ mọi người để ý nè. Tôi tổng
hợp thành from [âm nhạc] hoàn chỉnh. Thì
như vậy á lúc trước nếu như mà mình bình
thường nhá mình để mình build ra một cái
sản phẩm mọi người để ý nhá. Mình mình
mặc dù bây giờ mình bảo là antibt hay là
những cái công cụ này á nó đã có cái sức
mạnh rồi nó làm đầy đủ rồi mình nhưng mà
mình vẫn phải tương tác mình phải cung
cấp đầu vào cho nó khá là nhiều thông
tin đúng không cả nhà? vân vân mình phải
ngồi mình đánh câu Rom rồi mình phải
nhập đủ đầy. Còn với cái trường hợp
[âm nhạc]
cái Anti Dav 2.0 á nó có một cái hay là
nó sẽ hỏi mình và khi mà mình dùng cái
câu lệnh này nó sẽ bắt đầu tự đưa ra à
một cái bảng chi tiết hoàn chỉnh hơn thu
thập. Đây
để cho mọi người hình dung
teamwork project from ha. Và đây là cái
bảng draft thôi. Và dựa trên cái nhu cầu
một hồi nãy một cái câu khá là đơn giản
thôi thì nó đã sinh ra cho mình một cái
from chi tiết đầy đủ hơn. Ví dụ xây dựng
một trang web thương mại điện tử
[âm nhạc] Hàn Quốc cao cấp với thương
hiệu hư cấu do AI tạo ra, giao diện D
luxury vân vân. Hình ảnh do AI tạo sinh,
Generate AI nè. Đó, requirement, thương
hiệu vân vân. R2 là cái gì đấy.
À bắt đầu nó sẽ đi ra. Mọi người thấy
không? Nó sẽ đi từng thành phần, từng
chi tiết một. [âm nhạc] Thay vì nếu như
lúc trước mình build ra một trang web,
mọi người phải đọ, phải đánh đầy đủ. Và
nếu như anh chị nào làm bên cái lĩnh vực
này á sẽ để ý thêm cái này nè. Mình mình
mà làm bên lĩnh vực mà làm về bên phần
mềm á đúng ra [âm nhạc] là mình cái này
thì nó hơi chuyên môn cái từ có một cái
từ gọi là từ ba á à ba á là mình phải có
một cái người làm ba để phân tích à
trước khi mình giống như làm một cái ứng
dụng làm một cái cái cái bên công ty
phần mềm nó hay có một cái đội gọi là
[âm nhạc] pa.
Thì bên web cũng vậy họ sẽ đi thu thập
thông tin trước. Thì trước đây mình đã
từng làm một cái con chestbot đó để
chuyên đi đánh giá là thu thập những cái
việc mà làm trang web [âm nhạc] mình
cung cấp cho nó những cái thông tin gì
rồi đầy đủ những cái thông tin đó hay
chưa thì nó mới tạo ra cho mình những
cái này nè mọi người. Đó kiểu kiểu như
vậy nha. Thì mình hình dung ra á là bây
giờ chỉ với một câu cơ bản cái ông này
cũng làm hết ổ làm hết từ đầu cũng được.
Thì đây [âm nhạc] là một trong những cái
sức mạnh của nó. Tuy nhiên phải lưu ý
nhé Minh tạm ngừng cái chỗ này nãy giờ
loan nói chuyện thì trong cái buổi giới
thiệu của Google AI Google a iOS
[âm nhạc]
2026 của Google á thì họ có nói á vì cái
này nó chạy full start có nghĩa là nó đi
một mạch luôn nó đi một lèo nó chạy
ra luôn thành phẩm luôn nếu như mình có
không hạn chế nó kể cả đến cái việc là
setting [âm nhạc] này nè bỏ cái cơ chế
là full machine mà để cho nó tự động
thực thi không cần hỏi mình chọn onway
rit tự thực thi á thì lúc này mình
cần phải có một lượng cota đủ lớn quay
lại là vấn đề cota thôi phải đủ lớn tại
vì nó chạy liên tục và nó sẽ tự động
build không cần ngưng nghĩ thì ở đây
Google họ khuyên mình là nên chọn 3.5
Flash thì lúc này mình hôm bữa mình có
thử là mình build hai cái sản phẩm và
nếu như mọi người để ý là trong thời
gian vừa qua á [âm nhạc] thì có một cái
trên cộng đồng Antiav TVN thì nó có
build một cái trang đó là quản lý về cái
kho nhưng mà trang đó thì cũng phải mất
một ngày [âm nhạc]
để xong thì trong cái quá trình nó chạy
mình cứ để máy cho nó chạy thôi mọi
người nó hết cota xong rồi để đó rồi nó
hồi sinh lại thì nó tự động nó chạy tiếp
nó hồi sinh rồi mình lại [âm nhạc] enter
mình sẽ tiếp tục nó làm chạy tiếp thì
đâu đó cũng ít chạy từ gần một ngày á
nói như vậy chứ cũng gần một ngày tại vì
mình bị tạm ngưng ở giai đoạn mà mình
ngủ nghỉ á
chứ không phải là gì hết. Kế đến là mình
có làm một cái trang web mà mọi người
vừa rồi có để ý không biết là mọi người
có thấy không là một cái trang
rồi để chỗ này mình cho nó tiếp tục cái
nha.
Đó là một cái trang quản lý nhân sự của
bên mình đang làm. Thì cái trang đó hoàn
toàn được làm từ chính cái công
[âm nhạc] cụ
công cụ này từ chính cái nền tảng cái n
ông ông nội này
ừ anti 2.0 này được không cả nhà? Và tốc
độ sau khi mình làm xong á về tốc độ nhé
về tốc độ là sau khi mình làm xong
cái kinh nghiệm của cái trang web lần
trước là mình đã có kinh nghiệm cho cái
trang này được không cả nhà? Và lúc đó
bắt đầu mình build cái thằng này nó
nhanh [âm nhạc] hơn.
Sau khi mình build ông nội này nhanh hơn
rồi á thì mình đầu mình chỉ vào custom
thôi và
mình chỉnh sửa dần và mình xuất
[âm nhạc] rồi nội dung rồi
chấm công rồi vân vân. Đó thì lúc này
hoàn toàn là bằng trên antivat 2.0 à chứ
mình không hề có tác động ở trên cái nền
tảng ID tại vì lúc này nó chạy multient
và nó hỗ trợ cho mình nhanh hơn, thao
tác nhanh hơn.
Rồi ví dụ như trong trường hợp này mình
chọn ngày công nè. Đó rồi mình xất file
Excel thì đây nó [âm nhạc] sẽ ra được
cho mình cái file này. Ví dụ như file
Excel này bản công
để mọi người hình dung.
Cả nhà vẫn còn thấy cái màn hình của
Minh chỗ cái phá Excel đúng không ạ?
Đây.
Đó thì cái phần này là do mình mới tin
chỉnh cho đến đoạn này thôi nha. Mình
chưa làm thêm nha mọi người. Có nghĩa là
cái [âm nhạc] này tùy thuộc vào nhu cầu
của mọi người. Mọi người muốn làm thêm
cái tính năng gì mọi người chỉ cần cung
cấp và nói và trao đổi cũng giống như là
cái những cái trang web mà hoặc là những
cái [âm nhạc] tool mà anh chị đã làm
thôi. Đó thì quay lại cái chỗ này. Đó
đến cái chỗ này mọi người nhìn nè. Cái
trang web này nó tương đối, nó đơn giản
thì lúc này nó chỉ sử dụng gì ạ? Nó chỉ
sử dụng cơ bản là ở đây nó chỉ sử dụng
là hai sub agent. Có nghĩa là chỉ sử
dụng hai [âm nhạc] cái ờ hai cái bạn
mình hiểu cơ bản là hai bạn nhân viên để
chạy thôi. Cùng một lúc để coi ở
[âm nhạc] trong này nó chạy cái gì nha.
Rồi ở trong này nó sẽ sinh ra ha mọi
người nhìn thấy nè nó ở trong này nó lại
sinh ra một cái việc nữa là chỗ này à để
mình giải thích thêm nhé
cái tính năng của ai antiavity 2.0 Trong
này nó có một cái điểm hay là cái gì?
Khi mà à nó [âm nhạc] chạy cái sub agent
đó mọi người, chạy multiagent đầu tiên á
nó sẽ yêu cầu nó sẽ chạy ra một cái
giống như mình hiểu là mình là người
quản lý nhá, mình là [âm nhạc] ông sếp,
mình là giám đốc được không ạ? Mình giao
một nhiệm vụ cho một cái anh trưởng
phòng thì cái anh trưởng phòng đó ảnh
chắc chắn là ảnh là quản lý mà đã gọi là
trưởng phòng thì ảnh sẽ có nhân viên
đúng không ạ? Vậy thì nhân viên là sao
vậy? Thì tại sao mình không giao việc
xuống cho nhân viên họ làm như trưởng
phòng chỉ là quản lý thôi, còn làm gì
làm miễn sao trưởng phòng tổng hợp số
liệu và báo cáo về cho sếp là được đúng
không cả nhà? Thì cái
anh này Anti Davity 2.0 này nè nó đang
áp dụng theo kiểu đó. Nghĩa là ảnh sẽ
phân cấp, [âm nhạc] ảnh sẽ có một con
điều hành điều phối đó ảnh sẽ giao
xuống. [âm nhạc] Ví dụ như ở đây có bao
nhiêu cái trọng điểm à là
hai nhánh, ba nhánh, bốn nhánh gì đó tùy
[âm nhạc] theo cái chức năng và nhiệm
vụ, tùy theo cái công việc mình sẽ giao
xuống rồi để cho anh trưởng phòng nhân
sự, anh trưởng phòng kế toán, anh chưởng
phập tài chính ảnh làm việc và anh trong
cái anh đó thì anảnh giao xuống cho bao
nhiêu con nữa, bao nhiêu cái bạn nhân
viên nữa là do cái anh chữ phòng đó anh
phân bổ [âm nhạc] mà thôi. Vậy thì về
cái mô hình như vậy thì mình nói để cho
mọi người hình dung nhưng chi tiết á nó
sẽ có thêm một cái tính năng là cái gì?
Ở trong antiravity 2.0 này á nó sẽ có
một cái phần là
nó [âm nhạc] khi nó nhận lệnh từ ông sếp
giao xuống á thì ông trưởng phòng á ở
đây ổng sẽ đi giao ngẫu nhiên hay là
giao xuống [âm nhạc] cố định gọi là tự
động á thì nó còn phụ thuộc vào cái việc
là cái công việc nó nhiều hay ít nữa
nha. Nếu mà công việc đó nằm trong cái
khả năng của nó mà nó nó giống như nó tự
động nó tính toán. Còn mà mình tác động
vô thì mình phải dùng thêm câu lệnh. À
hôm trước mình có share lên trên một cái
nhóm của anh em bên AI thực thi đó mà
[âm nhạc] cái nhóm của mình làm hôm
trước đó mọi người. Thì anh em lật lại
cái tài liệu mà mình share. [âm nhạc] Ở
trong đó có một cái phần là khi mình
muốn khi mình muốn trực tiếp luôn can
thiệp vào luôn là tôi muốn với cái nhánh
con ở bên trong. Ví dụ như trong này ở
đây nè mọi người nhìn nó có tới tận năm
sub agent và năm sub agent này mỗi người
sẽ đảm gặp một vai [âm nhạc] trò mỗi mỗi
công việc gì thì cái này nó đang tự động
phân bổ nhưng mà trước đó ví dụ như mình
muốn là cái ông này nè ổng tự [âm nhạc]
động ổ can thiệp thì mình sẽ phải là
người đánh cái câu lệnh đó ra mình phải
rạch rồi ra mình đánh luôn cái câu lệnh
mà đánh luôn cái tên nó ra thì cái này
đòi hỏi mình phải [âm nhạc] ngồi mình
mình nghiên cứu mình mình làm thêm nha
mọi người thì hôm đó để ngồi làm cái này
thì Minh mất cũng khoảng đâu 1 ngày gần
2 ngày để chỉ mở việc là ngồi nghiên cứu
cái multiention nó hoạt động như thế nào
thôi. Chỉ để nghiên cứu mỗi việc đó
thôi. Và mình build đúng hai cái trang
web trong hai ngày đầu một ngày thì mất
lấy cái trang quản lý kho thì một ngày
sau để mất thêm một cái trang làm về
quản lý nhân sự này. Sau đó bắt đầu
build dần lên, build dần lên, build dần
lên. Đó [âm nhạc] thì nói như vậy không
có nghĩa là nó đi một phát là cái trang
ở này nó hoàn chỉnh nha mọi người mà
mình phải cải tiếng rồi mình phải custom
vân vân các kiểu.
[hắng giọng]
Đó thì những cái tính năng này là mọi
người hoàn toàn Minh làm từ cái nền tảng
bên cái antiraity đó và mình yêu cầu nó
thôi. Thì nói như vậy để mọi người hình
dung là cái [âm nhạc]
và thêm một cái nữa là cái gì? Cái ông
anti Gravity 2.0 này á mình khác biệt
với cái điểm mà của bên nền tảng Anti
Ideer là cái gì? Anti Gravity Ider là
cái gì? Khi mà nó chạy multiagent này
gần đây gần đây anh chị có nghe nhiều về
cái mô hình gọi là One Personal Company
đúng không ạ? OBC [âm nhạc] mình nghe
khá nhiều đúng không ạ? Và có rất là
nhiều khóa học hoặc là nhiều cộng đồng
đã chia sẻ về những cái cái cái kỹ thuật
để làm cái doanh nghiệp một người ứng
dụng bằng AI
đó. Nhưng mà nhưng mà nha mọi người để ý
nhé khi mình làm nhiều mình phải để ý
nhé mình làm với antiravity rồi mình
chưa làm bên clock mình không biết nha
tại vì clock gần đây nó có một cái mô
hình tương tự với cái multiagent này. Và
hôm vừa rồi mình cũng có xem một cái bài
đó luôn. mình phân tích cái bài đó nhưng
mà mình quay trở lại cái bài toán của
những anh chị đang dùng antiity thôi.
Thì khi mà chúng ta dùng công cụ Google
Anti Gravity mình chạy cái mô hình mà
nhiều gọi là đa gọi là đa nhân sự được
không? Được không cả nhà? Đa nhân sự một
ông điều hành giao [âm nhạc] xuống cho
ba ông dự phòng hay bốn ông chủ phòng
một ông mỗi ông một công việc chuyên
chấp.
Tuy nhiên mọi người phải hình dung là
thế này vì tính chất của nó, vì bản chất
của nó là mình phải hiểu bản chất
antibapti nó [âm nhạc] không có tính
năng multiasent cho nên khi nó hoạt động
về bản chất nó phải [âm nhạc] làm xong
việc này nó mới đến cái việc kia.
xong cái việc giống như là à ông tại vì
bản thân nó thực tế là chỉ có một cái
model đó mọi người. Một cái model chạy
một thời điểm nó không tự phân ra được
nhiều luồng. Nó không tự phân ra được
thành nhiều luồng được không ạ? Và chính
vì vậy nó phải chạy xong cái luồng này
nó mới đi đến cái luồng kế. [âm nhạc]
Mình hình dung có nghĩa là output của
cái này là input của cái kia và tiếp tục
như vậy là out của cái này lại tiếp tục
input của cái kia. Là cứ như vậy thì
[âm nhạc] lúc này nó sao ạ? cái gánh
nặng của nó đó nó về gánh nặng về thời
gian, gánh nặng về cota nè, token á. Còn
với cái mô hình Google [âm nhạc] Antia
Gravity 2.0 này nó có một cái ưu thế là
nó tận dụng được cái nguồn lực là nó
chia nhỏ ra trong cùng một cái [âm nhạc]
ô chat, trong cùng một cái luồng này.
Tuy nhiên là nó phân tấp nhiều luồng. À
đây mọi người thấy tới thời điểm này nó
vẫn đang chạy nha. Mặc dù mọi người mình
vẫn đang nói chuyện với nhau nhưng nhiệm
vụ của nó thì nó vẫn đang làm và tự động
nó đi phân bổ ra bao nhiêu
>> [âm nhạc]
>> bao nhiêu cái agent, bao nhiêu công đoạn
gì đó thì nó trong này nó vẫn đang chạy.
Ờ nó đang có hẫu mình thêm một cái chạy
vào sale không sao hết. Rồi thì mọi
người hình dung lúc này nó sẽ phân tách
ra nó tự động nó đi nó bổ nhỏ bổ nhỏ để
nó chạy [âm nhạc] nhiều luôn. Và cái cơ
chế này hôm trước chứng minh cũng đi hỏi
à cũng đào vào hỏi nó. Nếu như vậy thì
liệu rằng á, liệu rằng [âm nhạc] so với
cái việc là tôi chạy từng công đoạn một
output của cái này rồi mới tới input của
thằng kia rồi còn ở đây á là chạy song
song [âm nhạc] parallel thì cái nào tốn
cô ta nhiều hơn, cái nào ưu việt hơn
được không cả nhà?
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Thì khi đó mình mình bản thân mình cũng
có cái gọi là cái cái cái đa nhân cách
là mình hơi nghi nghi ngờ nhân sinh mình
cũng nghi ngờ là bản thân nó đang lừa
mình tại vì lần đầu tiên mình mới dùng
đó bạn cho nên mình cũng đi tìm hiểu cái
nguồn thông tin đó nha. À khi nó thực
thi nhiều luồng như vậy thì cái liệu
[âm nhạc] rằng cái cota nó đốt đốt ra nó
thật sự là nó đang lấy từ một luồng hay
là nó được tối ưu bởi cái công thức
riêng của nó. Thì khi mà mình yêu cầu nó
phân tích như vậy á, mình không đứng từ
trong cái con này, mình lại mang cái
[âm nhạc] luồng dữ liệu mà chính cái câu
hỏi đó mình lại mang qua bên cái công cụ
khác nhé. Mình mang qua cái con Codex
[âm nhạc] à mình có sử dụng cái con
Codex à là chat GPT của Open chứ không
phải là chat GPT nhá. Hãng Codex.
[âm nhạc] Và mình mang qua bên một cái
ông nữa đó là con Rock AI và một cái con
nữa là Black City. Mình lấy những cái
thông tin mà mình tổng hợp được không cả
nhà? Mình đặt câu hỏi lại [âm nhạc] bên
các nền tảng AI khác để cho nó trả lời
lại là có đúng là cái cách vận hành của
cái model Anti [âm nhạc] Gravity 2.0 này
nó như vậy hay không.
Tại vì cái cái nhân sinh quan của mình
nó hơi đa nhân cách tí xíu. Kiểu như vậy
mình nói thì nó hơi ấy nhưng mà mình
phải hình dung được là sau khi mình tìm
hiểu xong thì tụ trung lại tụ trung lại
là cái bài toán mà của ông Google này
khi nó ra được cái multiagation này là
đúng [âm nhạc] là tối ưu tối ưu về cả
thời gian về toen ha. Tối ưu về thời
gian và kể cả toen [âm nhạc] khi mà chạy
đa nhiệm. Mình có thể hiểu như vậy gọi
là chạy đa nhiệm đó. Cho nên bắt đầu kể
từ cái hôm đó [âm nhạc] trở đi á khi
những cái bài toán mà mình cần chạy
nhiều luồng ở trong đây mình có
[âm nhạc] những cái bài toán là chạy
nhiều luồng nhé. Ví dụ như mình tổng hợp
tin tức có liên quan đến cái đầu việc mà
[âm nhạc] mình đang làm. Tin tức về
những cái sân thể thao vân vân. Mình
đang làm kiểu kiểu như vậy [âm nhạc] thì
lúc này nó đi tổng hợp thông tin lại.
Tổng hợp thông tin giúp mình. Nhưng mà
lúc này mình sẽ yêu cầu nó là cái gì ạ?
một ngày bạn chạy [âm nhạc] cho tôi là
đây. Ví dụ như
ở trong đây mình có
những cái phần mà mình hay có làm.
[âm nhạc]
Ok. Thôi mình lấy cái nội dung mới đi.
Trong cái quá trình nó đang chạy thì
mình lại làm tiếp tục một cái nội dung
khác nha. À
ví dụ đây cái này
trend
mình tạo ra mấy [âm nhạc] cái skill này
cũng lung tuân skill để cho nó đi nó
quét cái dữ liệu. Đây ở trong này mọi
người nhìn [âm nhạc] thấy là mình riêng
cái phần này không mình đã có hai cái
skill khác nhau. Một cái là cái skill
tập trung vào tìm cái a đại khái là mình
tạo ra hai cái này. Một cái là tạo luôn
cả hình ảnh. Một cái là chỉ lấy content
thôi. Một cái là lấy được content xong
thì phải tạo luôn hình ảnh. Kiểu như vậy
đó. Rồi bây giờ mình chạy một cái thử
cái đi.
Thì lúc này nhá, bản thân nó sẽ đi chạy
ra cái skill này. Trong đây nó có tùy
cái trường hợp mà nó sẽ nó sẽ tự động nó
bổ nhỏ cái công việc đó ra. Bổ nhỏ cái
công việc đó ra. Chạy nhiều luồng cùng
một lúc ha. Nó chạy nhiều luồng cùng một
lúc. Nhưng có thời điểm nó
nó không có có có chạy cái này nhiều.
Một luồng một lúc lên chỗ này [âm nhạc]
thì mọi người sẽ không thấy được. À để
mình mở thêm một cái này nữa cho anh chị
nhìn nó rõ [âm nhạc] hơn. Đây nè.
Ok, mình sẽ tặng bớt cái chỗ này
mình sẽ
đây
Mình để vào trong cái ô chat nha mọi
người. À
mọi người thử nếu mà ai đang dùng 2.0
thì bắt đầu mình có thể thử cùng mình
nhé. Mình sẽ lấy một cái mẫu thử
[âm nhạc] đây. Hãy nghiên cứu và phân
tích tình hình kinh tế chính trị toàn
cầu năm 2016 đánh giá tác động đến ngành
năng lượng tái tạo của Việt Nam. À spa
năm sub [âm nhạc] chạy song song. Mỗi
sub phụ trách một khu vực à bao gồm Mỹ,
EU, Trung Quốc, Đông Nam [âm nhạc] Á,
Trung Đông. À thì mỗi con subention này
nó có nhiệm vụ gì ạ? Thu thập [âm nhạc]
tin tức nè, phân tích xu hướng nè, xác
định rủi ro cơ hội cho khu vực đó. Khi
tất cả xong bị tổng hợp thành một file
báo cáo MC down à có cái gì đó vân vân
summariz bạn so sánh khu vực khuyến nghị
hành động gì vân vân cho doanh [âm nhạc]
nghiệp Việt Nam về cái năng lượng mặt
trời. Rồi mình tạm thời à [âm nhạc] tạm
thời copy hết này luôn. Rồi mọi người có
thể nếu như ai đang có chạy antibity
cái này nó chạy
nhiều quá hốn cota nữa tạm thời mình
lưng và cho nó thử chỗ này để cho mọi
người nhìn nó rõ hơn.
New project
đây.
Rồi trong cái lúc mà nó đang chạy cái
câu này thì mọi người để mình lướt thêm
cái phần à cái trang này nó chưa chạy
xong. cái trang web ban đầu mình làm
cùng với mọi người
thì lúc này mọi người thấy nó sẽ phân
tích xong nhé. Nó sẽ bắt đầu nó sinh
[âm nhạc] ra nó sinh ra ở đây nó để là
những cái
à
gọi là subent.
Còn cái từ mà chuyên môn nhá. Ở trong
đây nó có một cái từ gọi là từ chuyên
môn. À mình
chia sẻ thêm chỗ này để mọi người chung
cái từ spaw là sinh ra được không cả
nhà? Nếu như mình dùng tiếng Việt nó vẫn
hiểu nhé. Nó vẫn hiểu có nghĩa là hãy
sinh ra, hãy tạo ra năm sub agent được
không cả nhà? nó vẫn hiểu. Tuy nhiên
theo như lúc mà mình tra cứu tài liệu,
mình ngồi [âm nhạc] mình làm việc với
Anti Davity á thì cái từ spaw này là cái
từ xác nghĩa với nó nhất và nó hình dung
rõ nhất. Và dĩ nhiên á nó chỉ là từ tốt
nhất thôi chứ không có nghĩa là mình nói
cái từ là hãy tạo cho tôi năm sub agent
là nó không hiểu. Không [âm nhạc] phải
mình nói câu tiếng Việt bình thường nó
vẫn hiểu. Tuy nhiên do mình mình hình
dung ra được cái [âm nhạc] cái cái cái
câu đó rồi cho nên mình gán nó luôn vào
bên trong cái câu lệnh này. Vậy đó để
cho mọi người dễ hình dung thôi. Rồi thì
đến đoạn này bắt đầu mọi người mọi người
bắt đầu nhìn nhé. Nó đang chạy là năm
sub agent. Và nếu như ai đang chạy về
anti gravity ideal thì thử cùng copy cái
câu này mang qua cái nền tảng bên kia để
chạy thử [âm nhạc] xem thử nó hoạt động
như thế nào. Mọi người sẽ có cái bài
toán một cái bức tranh nhìn rõ hơn. Rồi
là mình đang chạy ở trong cái middle
earth [âm nhạc] economic. Rồi đây là một
cái subent ở bên trên. Và tới [âm nhạc]
cái đoạn là US Economic thì nó cũng đang
chạy ha. Rồi tiếp tục để xem coi cái ông
xe nà.
Đó nó sẽ đ cũng đang chạy ở đây cùng một
thời điểm nha một lúc nó sẽ chạy ra à
rất là nhiều cái cái cái tab.
Và mọi người thấy nè nó sẽ báo ra ở đây
cho mình thấy là hệ thống sẽ tự động
đánh thức. Tôi khi các sub agent hoàn
thành và gửi lại kết quả, tôi sẽ tiến
hành tổng hợp là cái con này nó giống
như một cái con điều phối đó mọi người.
Cái con gọi [âm nhạc] là mình hồi nãy
mình gọi là ông giám đốc á, ông quản lý
đó. Thì ở đây là nó chờ các ông kia đi
thao tác, đi [âm nhạc] thực thi xong thì
nó
mới tổng hợp nó gọi là báo cáo cho mình
được không cả nhà? Ở đây nó sẽ sinh ra
một cái file báo cáo lưu trữ trên này.
Đây
đây là nó chưa xong nhé. Ờ kiểu như
[âm nhạc] vậy và nó còn vẫn còn đang
thao tác ở đây. Thì trong này nó chỉ là
một file báo cáo tổng và nếu như chi
tiết à nó có một cái file tổng file báo
cáo chi tiết nữa nha mọi người.
Đây mình sẽ mở ra từng cái [âm nhạc]
global
đây mọi người nhìn nhé. Global
Global Summary
đó.
À nếu như cùng một cái câu lệnh này mọi
người mang qua thử cái công qua cái nền
tảng mà Anti Gravity Ider thì mọi người
sẽ thấy cái tốc độ lấy dữ liệu, tổng hợp
dữ liệu để mọi người sẽ có cái bài toán
là so sánh rõ hơn nó như thế nào liền
được không cả nhà? và xem cái cách nó
vận hành, cái cách nó thực thi.
Rồi ở đây nó có báo về lại cho mình nhé.
Báo cáo chi tiết là master là cái cái
file này.
Ờ
rồi
và tất cả hồi nãy là mọi người thấy á
trong cái quá trình ở đây nó chạy là mỗi
một con sẽ đi truy cập Internet để lấy
thông tin chứ nó rõ ràng nó không phải
tự bịa ha. nó sẽ đưa vào từng con một,
từng chi tiết một [âm nhạc] để lấy thông
tin à nó đi research á. Rồi ở trong này
[âm nhạc] nếu như mà mọi người mà làm
nhiều á mọi người sẽ thấy là nó chỉ đây
là file giống như cái file gọi là file
report tổng thôi. File report tổng nha.
Mà mình muốn coi chi tiết từng một, từng
nội dung, từng quốc gia. À nó có luôn
nha. Từng ông một. Ví dụ như trong cái
ông thị trường EU,
thị trường [âm nhạc] EU rồi thị trường
Mỹ, thị trường Trung Đông.
Đó, đây là ngành năng lượng báo cáo là
chính trị ở Trung Đông rồi. EU nó như
thế nào thì lúc này mọi người sẽ thấy
không?
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Minh chỉ đánh là tạm thời cái đó là cơ
bản để mọi người có một cái bài toán
thôi. Còn lại là mình có thể chi tiết
hóa nó ra tùy theo nhu cầu thì mọi người
sẽ có cái bài toán rõ ràng hơn. Nhưng
quay lại cái trận tâm mà mình muốn trao
đổi là cái công cụ Anti Gravity 2.0 này
nó có những cái ưu điểm là cái gì để mọi
người sẽ có thêm [âm nhạc] cái sự lựa
chọn. Ngoài ra nhé, ngoài ra một cái ưu
điểm nữa là trong cái quá trình mình làm
với cái công cụ này mình thấy một
[âm nhạc] cái điểm nữa ở trên Antia
Gravity 2.0 à nó có những cái ưu điểm
khá nhiều mà mình buộc phải dùng nó là
đúng nghĩa luôn. Rồi thì trong cái quá
trình để mình quay lại cái trang web coi
nó build tới đâu rồi.
À nó vẫn nhiệt tình nó vẫn đang chạy
luôn.
Tại vì nãy mình lựa chọn khá là nhiều
cái chi tiết và [âm nhạc] nó có thể là
nó buill ra một cái trang còn rất là
nhiều cái công việc ở trong này nó chưa
xong.
Scal thì cái điểm này là mọi người không
biết có ai có biết cái về cái tính năng
scedule [âm nhạc] cron này hay chưa ha?
Cái tính năng này rất là hay ở trên
antigravity mới nha. Mọi người có thể
tham khảo thêm. [âm nhạc] À đây nó còn ở
đây nó còn đang thao tác
nó vẫn còn đang thực thi ở bên trong này
nó còn đang tới riêng cái phần M1 này
mọi người nhìn nhé riêng cái phần M1 này
nó tự phân ra cho nó là 16 [âm nhạc] sub
và riêng đến cái phần E2E này nó lại
tiếp tục phân cho tiếp là bảy sub agent
bên trong mỗi một cái [âm nhạc] đầu mục
nhỏ nó lại tiếp tục phân ra phân ra phân
ra mọi người nhìn nhé. Và tự bên trong
nó sẽ tự đi build ra một cái cái cái cái
đầu việc cái câu lệnh mà nó phải yêu cầu
bên trong [âm nhạc] phải làm cái gì đó
nha mọi người. Còn cái form này là form
tổng thôi nhưng mà nó sẽ bám theo cái
này.
À ở đây nó có phần chi tiết nè. Thì đối
để nó tôi bắt đầu với trường hợp là E2E
thì nó phải tạo ra cái gì vân vân nó
phải đợi rất là nhiều á thì mình cũng
không có bám sát được hết cái này đâu
mọi người.
Đó thì mình nói như vậy thì quay lại cái
bài toán là để mọi người hình dung với
cái công cụ này nó tự động nó thực thi
mọi người sẽ còn trong cái quá trình này
mọi người sẽ có những cái công cụ khác
chứ nó không chỉ dừng lại ở cái
team [âm nhạc]
à teamw review nhé. Ok để mình sẽ đi
thêm một cái tính năng nữa.
Thì cái tính năng này nãy mình nói rồi
đã triển khai thử cái multiagent để mọi
người thấy về cái thao tác của nó ha.
Rồi thì thêm một cái tính năng mà theo
mình nó khá là hay ở trên cái antiravity
mới mà mọi người nên tận dụng. Mọi người
nên tận dụng kết hợp trong cái quá trình
mình à làm [âm nhạc] web, làm app
gì mình cảm thấy rằng nó phức tạp. Cảm
thấy rằng nó phức tạp nhé. Mọi người nên
thêm [âm nhạc] cái cái dấu xệt này là
Realme được không cả nhà? Tính năng
Realme đó kết hợp. Nếu như bình thường
gần đây [âm nhạc] chính mình cũng làm
như vậy luôn. Bên Realme cộng thêm cái
team hồi nãy là mình chỉ mới nói TeamW
[âm nhạc] thôi mọi người đó. Nhưng khi
mình kết hợp Realme cộng với [âm nhạc]
Teamwork Review thì nó sẽ như thế nào ạ?
Cái Realme chính là cái interview
[âm nhạc] là nó đi phỏng vấn ngược lại
mình. Ví dụ như cùng làm một cái trang
web hồi nãy nó có gợi ý cho mình những
cái đầu ngục kia [âm nhạc] đúng không?
Nhưng sẽ có một số trường hợp à nó sẽ
không gợi ý mà nó thiếu đi cái tính năng
à đặt câu hỏi ngược lại với mình, phỏng
vấn mình à là bạn cần bổ sung cái này
hay bạn muốn làm cái gì vân vân. Thì để
mình bắt nó phải hỏi mình trước thì ở
đây tính năng gọi là Realme là interview
đó. Nó có chữ interview luôn mọi người.
Đó là phẩm vấn mình hỏi [âm nhạc] mình
trước. Ví dụ nhé mình chỉ đặt một câu
hỏi ở trong cái trường hợp này thôi nhé.
À tôi muốn
nâng cấp
các câu hủ à câu mình đánh đại đó nha.
[âm nhạc]
Nâng cấp
from cho câu
1 ban đầu
thì nên làm sao
để coi nó có hỏi gì theo mình không
nghe.
Đó cái này mình lấy đại một cái ví dụ để
mọi người dễ hình dung thôi.
Nếu như trong trường hợp nãy mình không
có chữ Realme [âm nhạc] mà mình chỉ đặt
một cái câu cơ bản là tôi muốn nâng cấp
from cho câu hỏi ban đầu là ở phía trên
cùng. Hồi nãy mình đang đi khảo sát,
mình dùng cái khảo sát thị [âm nhạc]
trường đó theo kiểu như vậy đi. Thì lúc
này mình thêm cái chữ Realme thì mọi
người thấy chuyện gì xảy ra nó sẽ đặt ra
cho mình nè recommand là tự động hóa quy
trình phân tích và đóng gói báo cáo ở
định dạng cao cấp gì đây. [âm nhạc] Bạn
muốn cái gì mình chọn cái đó nha. Mở
rộng số hai, mở rộng vi phân tích sang
các ngành kinh tế, xã hội, nâng cấp chất
lượng, chuẩn hóa và cái mục số năm là
mình có thể bỏ qua. Order không phải là
bỏ qua, mình xin lỗi mình tự đánh cái
mình mong muốn. Thay vì mình đọc hết
những cái câu nó đề xuất mình thấy không
hợp lý mình tự đánh mình tự đánh thêm
cái nội dung của mình vào. Và cái phần
Realme này nó có một cái điểm hay là nó
tự động cho mình cái [âm nhạc]
multijoiny luôn là trong cái quá trình
mà nó đề suốt nó gợi ý. Thậm chí có
những cái đề xuất là cần [âm nhạc] nhiều
sự lựa chọn. Nó tự động nó cho mình chọn
là multioy.
Multi luôn. À nó có điểm [âm nhạc] hay
như thế. Rồi Minh tự đi qua với cái phần
này
Minh chọn đại nhé. Thì bắt đầu nó sẽ
thực thi đó và nó lại tiếp tục thấy
chưa? Chưa đủ thông tin. Bạn muốn tích
hợp định dạng cao cấp này vào quy trình
đóng gói tự động của form mới à như thế
nào là xuất cả [âm nhạc] hai cái định
dạng cả PDF hay là chỉ định thì ở trong
này ở đây mình nó tự đề suốt là cái nghị
định theo nghị định 30 là do hôm trước
mình làm một cái quyết định mà ban hành
mà tự động hóa đó mọi người trong cái
buổi Zoom
à sáng ngày thứ bảy tuần [âm nhạc] vừa
rồi thì Minh có làm một cái tự động hóa
về cái làm cái việc là tạo ra một cái
quyết định theo chuẩn nghị định 30 cho
một cái ông nào đó vân vân thì chỉ cần
với một cái câu lệnh là ví dụ như ông
đổi Tuấn Minh nhập vào là tự động nó tạo
ra một cái quyết định hoàn [âm nhạc]
chỉnh à ông này là được phổ nhiệm vào vị
trí gì đấy thì có thể là do cái chỗ đó
mà nó nhớ đến cái chỗ cái phần là cái
phần này. Rồi như vậy thì ở đây mình sẽ
chọn thêm cái phần này chứ không phải là
tự động nó đưa ra thêm cái cái cái này
nha mọi người. Tự nhiên ở đâu ra được
cái này không có đâu. Ok thử thôi. Rồi
thì nó đề xuất như vậy thì mọi người
hình dung ra nó hỏi mình cứ trả lời cuối
cùng thì là cái gì ạ? Mục đích sau cùng
là cái gì ạ? Ý mình muốn nói [âm nhạc]
là cái phần Realme này nó sẽ cho mình
cái nội dung cuối cùng mà mong muốn trả
về á nó sẽ bám sát hơn với cái mình cái
kết quả đầu ra của mình. Thay vì trong
cái phần đầu tiên mình vẫn còn đang rất
mơ hồ thì mình nhờ cái câu lệnh Realme
này nó sẽ cho [âm nhạc] mình ra cái kết
quả nó chuẩn chỉ hơn và nhanh hơn, chất
lượng hơn. Thay vì mất thời gian để mà
cứ ngồi đánh từng [âm nhạc] câu, đánh
từng câu đánh từng công rồi cứ đi chỉnh
sửa là lại đánh từng câu rồi lại đi
chỉnh sửa đánh từng câu được không cả
nhà?
Đó, đây là một trong những phần mà mình
cũng hay áp dụng gần đây để mà [âm nhạc]
sử dụng cái tính năng Realme cộng với
tính năng Teamwork Review. À Minh cũng
phải nói thêm nhé, cái tính năng mà
Teamwork review thì nó chỉ có trên
[âm nhạc] tài khoản Ultra. Còn hiện nay
Realme thì có trên kể cả Google TWT Ider
và bản 2.0. Còn team review thì chỉ có
trên bản Ultra mà thôi.
À Ultra mà mà tài khoản Ultra thì mới
dùng được trên 2.0 nhé.
Đó thì lúc này để coi nó nâng cấp cải
tiến cái mẫu from nó như thế nào. Đây
sau khi cái mẫu form ban đầu của mình á
là phân góc có đạo ngắn kia bây giờ mình
yêu cầu nó nâng cấp lên đi thì nó nâng
cấp cho mình là phân tích địa chính trị
vĩ mô đa ngành tự động hóa đóng gói theo
nghị định 30 bao gồm luôn cả slide BBTX
là bao bo dưới đây là form được tối ưu
hóa toàn diện theo cấu trúc grap gì đó
vân vân rồi bối cảnh vai trò action bước
một bước hai bước ba bước bốn bước gì đó
vân vân. Trời ơi nhiều quá. Thì đó để
cho mọi người hình dung là nó đặt câu
hỏi sau khi có Realme rồi thì cái cái
kết quả đầu ra á nó sẽ khác hoàn toàn so
với cái lúc ban đầu nếu mình chỉ hỏi một
câu ngắn gọn được không cả nhà? Hỏi một
câu là tôi muốn nâng cấp hết là nó sẽ đi
ngay vào vấn đề luôn. Nó không có cần
hỏi tiếp.
Rồi thì đó là cái phần mà mình muốn đề
cập đến mọi người à nên tận dụng nó.
Quay lại cái chỗ này tí xíu nhá. Mình
coi coi cái trang web ban đầu mình cùng
với mọi người làm coi nó đã xong chưa
được trời nó chưa xong luôn. Ờ
đó thì mọi người mọi người làm một cái
dự án mà mọi người làm một cái gì đó là
ở đây nó sẽ có thêm cái cái nó nó tự thi
á mọi người bám vào chung là mọi người
nhìn thử coi nó còn chỗ nào nha. Tại vì
nãy giờ mình đang ngồi cùng với mọi
người nên mình cũng không có để ý.
À tuy nhiên á là ở đây nó có một cái
điểm hay như thế này nữa mọi người. Giả
định nhất giả định mọi người để ý hồi
nãy mình có nhắc đến cái trường hợp
sceduron này. Scuron này nó tự động nhé
nó tự động nó lập ra một cái kế hoạch
một cái [âm nhạc] schedule để làm gì ạ?
Trong cái quá trình mà
nó thực thi. Lỡ như [âm nhạc] hết cot.
Nếu như sao ạ? Bình thường như bình
thường nhá. hết cota thì lúc này nó sẽ
ngưng không thịch thêm nữa. Nhưng với
cái thao tác là chạy trên cái
team Work Review này á nó build ra đúng
nghĩa là một cái full start nó bao gồm
luôn cả scedule ron này. Khi nó
[âm nhạc] thực thi đến đây rồi mà ông
cái ông model này ổng hết cô ta mất tiêu
rồi ổng ngưng. Nhưng mà máy mình thì cứ
treo hôm bữa mình treo nguyên đêm luôn
mọi người. Mình treo nguyên đêm luôn.
Thì đến đoạn sáng á thì mình đến cái máy
của mình nó tắt thì mình mở máy lên thì
nó lại lập tức nó chạy tiếp. Nó canh
đúng cái giờ đó đến đoạn đó. Đúng giờ
đó. Đây mình bấm vào đây để mọi người
hình dung ra. À nó có một cái phần
à cái này thì không không không đúng.
Cái cái roll hồi nãy bên trong á nó mới
đúng cái roll đó. Còn cái này á thì một
cái nữa mọi người có thể tự lập kế hoạch
để [âm nhạc] đi cập nhật dữ liệu nhé.
Cập nhật dữ liệu online theo thời gian
mình mong muốn. Ví dụ [âm nhạc] sáng
6:00 7:00 hay là trưa 1100, chiều đầu
giờ 1:00, cuối giờ là 5:00 thì [âm nhạc]
mình chỉ yêu cầu nó với một cái câu lệnh
thông thường thôi mọi người. Ở trong này
thật ra nó có một cái c
start này để đây luôn rồi. Hoặc là mọi
người gõ vào cái câu lệnh là câu xệt rồi
mọi người dính đánh cái cái [âm nhạc]
schedule này, còn không là mọi người tự
nhập rồi bấm vào new. Thì đây là một
trong cái tính năng mới được đưa vào bên
trong cái antiraity này. Bên IDER nó
cũng có cái tính năng này mình đánh giá
nó rất là hay nhé. để thực thi tự động
hóa những công việc của mình mà theo
lệnh trình mà đôi khi mình bị quên đó
mọi người. Thì à ở đây ở đây Minh giả
định nhất à
hãy
tạo
cho tôi
lịch từ lịch lịch gì đây ta?
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Quét tin tức
tức định kỳ
mỗi sáng
lúc 6:00 7:00 đây bằng
skill
ừ ral [âm nhạc]
đây rồi hãy tạo cho tôi lịch web tin tức
định kỳ mỗi sáng [âm nhạc] gì ha thử coi
nó như thế nào nha mọi người. Thì mọi
người sẽ để ý nè.
Đó [âm nhạc] chỉ như vậy thôi. Xong rồi
đó. Tôi đã thiết lập thành công web tin
tức định kỳ hàng ngày. Chi tiết lịch web
thời gian là 7:00 sáng. hành động là
kích quạt cái skill [âm nhạc] này chạy ở
chế độ with scan cho dân shop từ khóa
trong cái cấu hình này. [âm nhạc] Tab ID
là tab thứ tám đó thì mọi người thấy là
coi cái lịch này nó đang nằm ở dưới và
nó chạy đây. Lịch nó lọc ra như thế này
được không cả nhà? Và cái phần output
thì nó đẩy dữ liệu về đây. Ở đây là mình
chỉ nói cơ bản nha mọi người có thể tự
cấu hình tự [âm nhạc]
thao tác thêm. Nhưng như vậy là để mọi
người hình dung ra là cái tính năng này
nó đúng nghĩa là giúp cho mình là tự
động hóa luôn.
À [âm nhạc] đúng à đúng
đúng chị. Rồi. Ừ. Ừ như vậy thì
[âm nhạc] cái phần này mình chỉ cần nói
với câu lệnh nó thì ban ngày, ban đêm,
ban trưa gì đó nó kết hợp với những cái
công cụ khác nó giúp cho mình hoàn toàn
đúng [âm nhạc] nghĩa là tự động hóa luôn
đó mọi người. Mình cũng có một vài cái
thấy nó hay
rồi để quay lại cái trường hợp này xem
thử coi
nó còn cái thao tác gì mà nó chưa xong
để lấy trang web ra cho mọi người xem.
Nó còn quay đây
còn vướng ở chỗ ông nào đó.
Hôm trước Minh có tạo [âm nhạc] ra một
cái tình huống nha. Mình có tạo ra một
cái bộ skill để chuyên làm về
tự mình tạo ra đa gọi là đa phòng ban
đa đa phòng ban gọi là đa subent để phục
vụ cho những cái đầu việc khác nhau.
Mình có tạo ra một cái bộ skill đó tùy
theo mục đích của mình ứng dụng mà mình
nhập vào công việc của mình đầu tiên là
nhập [âm nhạc] vào input đầu vào là công
việc gì thì bắt đầu nó đưa phân bổ ra.
Ở đây nó [âm nhạc] còn nhiều cái công
việc mình phải đi coi nó coi. À ở đây nó
còn chạy
coi [âm nhạc] coi nó hướng cái gì nó còn
lập cái lịch nó đang chạy schedule đây
chưa xong.
À
một này nữa
còn rất là nhiều. Vậy là nó chưa xong.
Và lịch của nó kế tiếp [âm nhạc] là vào
lúc 20:50.
Đúng ra là tới đây là nó phải thực thi
thì
không sao. Thì cái này là một cái bài
toán thôi, một cái cây study để cho mọi
người hình dung ra nhé. Thì cái cách vận
hành của công cụ Anti Gravity 2.0 này.
Như vậy thì quay lại [âm nhạc] cái chủ
đề của buổi hôm nay á ý mình muốn nói
rằng là cái gì ạ? Tại sao mình lại
chuyển sang mình thích dùng cái công cụ
Anti Gravity 2.0 này? [âm nhạc] Nhưng
không có nghĩa rằng không có nghĩa rằng
là mình rời bỏ cái công cụ antiity
không nha mọi người. Vì sao ạ? Vì có
những cái trường hợp khi mình muốn can
thiệp vào bên trong cái skill đó, can
thiệp vào nội dung bên trong của cái
project đó, của cái thư mục đó thì lúc
này cái bên này nó rất là bất tiện. Đúng
nghĩa là bất tiện luôn đúng. Và khi mình
làm xong rồi, bây giờ mình muốn nhìn
thấy cái giao diện, thấy cái nội dung cơ
bản của cái đó nó đã có những cái thành
phần gì rồi thì bên cái ông Antiravity
2.0 [âm nhạc] á nó lại không show ra
được cái nội dung bên trong. Mình rất là
ức chế. Cho nên á buộc lòng mình phải
sao ạ? Mình lại qua bên này [âm nhạc]
mình lại mở thêm một cái cửa sổ bên này.
Thế là sử dụng song song. Và có những
lúc mình mình nói là cùng một lúc luôn
mình thao tác [âm nhạc] hai cái ông này
cùng một lúc. Bên này nó đang chạy rồi
đúng không? Đây mọi người cái này thì
cái cái B conversation của mình nó cũng
cũ rồi. Bữa giờ mình ít dùng nó lại nè.
Mọi người thấy [âm nhạc] khoảng cách đây
một tuần lễ rồi à nhưng mà để mình mở
cho mọi người xem thử cái này
cái này là cái
cái cái
a cái làm việc song song mà hôm bữa mà
mình đang làm đóng gói cái notebook mà
mình chia sẻ ở trên cái
à trang cá nhân vừa rồi đại khái là như
vậy đó mọi người thấy ha. Thì Minh đầu
tiên cũng làm [âm nhạc] từ cái ông nội
2.0 này làm từ cái ông này nè. Mình cũng
yêu cầu ổng là tạo ra nhiều sub agent đi
tổng hợp tin tức a lộn không phải là
tổng hợp cái nội dung về cái
ông Nob cho mình. Tổng hợp nội dung nó
research ở đâu đó không biết nhưng mà nó
phải bán theo cái cấu trúc của mình yêu
cầu. Sau khi nó làm xong á thì [âm nhạc]
ở đây là mình có một cái thư mục là về
giáo trình với lại cái buổi đào tạo của
mình ở trong này là riêng.
Đây nè, đào tạo nè. Đó, thì đại khái là
như vậy. Và mình kêu nó làm xong nhưng
mà cái phần nội dung á, cái phần nội
dung á mình lại bị ức chế là mình không
nhìn được. Mình bị ức chế, mình không
nhìn được là mỗi khi nó phát sinh ra cái
nội dung bên trong nó như thế nào. À nó
nó cứ kiểu kiểu bị bên như kim màu tối
[âm nhạc] rồi không biết thư mục bên
trong đã có bao nhiêu tư mục, bao nhiêu
tập tin. Thì lúc này lúc này mình lại
bay qua mình mở thêm một cái ông bên này
nữa [âm nhạc] được không cả nhà? Như vậy
thì quay lại à mình sẽ cân bằng tùy theo
tính chất công việc được không cả nhà?
Với cái kinh nghiệm của Minh thôi nha.
Còn lúc này tùy theo mọi người sẽ có
cách dùng khác nhau. Thì Minh sẽ dùng ở
bên kia đối với những công việc nặng
nhọc. Đối với [âm nhạc] những công việc
nặng nhọc à cần phải mang tính chất là
đa gọi là ờ cần có cái cái cái đa nhiệm
á. cần đa nhiệm thì lúc này thảy qua cho
cái ông nọ này ổng làm [âm nhạc] được
không cả nhà? Còn cái công việc nào mà
mang tính chất mà thuần mà chúng ta đã
quen với đầ việc mà trước giờ bên Google
Ider rồi á. Đó thì mình tại vì nó cho
mình mở cùng một lúc được mà. Cùng một
lúc mình mở hai cửa sổ, hai cái này được
mà cùng thư mục. Mở cùng thư mục vẫn
được mà chỉ là mình gài thêm câu lệnh vô
ở bên trong đó là ví dụ như mình yêu cầu
á mọi người mình tạo ra bộ quy tắc thôi
mình kêu nó không được can thiệp khi mà
chỉnh sửa là [âm nhạc] không được xóa à
tập tin gốc không được thay đổi nội dung
gốc nếu có làm á thì
sao chép ra bảng sao y ví dụ vậy
[âm nhạc] thì về cơ bản thì cái đó là
các ai cũng biết rồi đúng không ạ thì
mình nói như vậy để cho mọi người hình
dung
tùy tình huống mà mình áp dụng như vậy
thôi.
Giống như cái ngoài đời [âm nhạc] thực
vậy đó. Công việc nào mà nặng quá mình
làm không nổi. Bê quân bát như mình ốm
yếu mình làm không nổi. Thôi mình thảy
qua cho ông nào ông khỏe ông làm việc
đó. Còn mình làm bàn giấy, mình ngồi
trên máy tính quen rồi thì mình làm mình
nhận việc đó. Kiểu như vậy đó mọi người.
Đó thì cũng giống như anh chị mà ngồi
nghe trong các diễn đàn công nghệ
khi mọi người chia sẻ thì mọi người nói
là cái gì ạ? Đưa cho con clot đúng không
ạ? Đưa cho con clot lên kế hoạch
[âm nhạc] làm cái phân tích a b c gì
đấy. Sau đó là đưa ngược về cho con
antiravity. à hay là con Codec là người
đi thực thi cũng kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thì
với trường hợp này bản thân Minh đánh
giá nếu [âm nhạc] như cần làm việc nặng
cần multiagent đa nhiệm thì mình sẽ cho
cái ờ công cụ bên [âm nhạc] 2.0 này nó
làm. Ngược lại thì trong số trường hợp
còn lại thì mình lại qua bên kia. Vậy
thôi. Thì đây [âm nhạc] là một vài cái
chia sẻ trong cái buổi tối hôm nay. Thì
để mình a
mọi người đợi mình tí xíu nha.
Ở trong này có những anh chị là người
mới. Chiều nay mình cũng thấy có một
người mới có hỏi về cái vấn đề này nhưng
mà sẵn đây để mình chia sẻ. Thì lúc đầu
tiên khi mới sử dụng anti 2.0 Không, cái
khó chịu nhất đúng nghĩa luôn là cái khó
chịu nhất là mọi người chưa quen á là
khi mà nó thao tác nó thực thi á nó sẽ
luôn hỏi mình ấ cứ bấm yes rồi bấm yes.
Ở bên Google Antiity Ideer cũ mình sẽ có
cài được [âm nhạc] extension đúng không
ạ? là chỗ này là auto accept là nó sẽ tự
động [âm nhạc]
on yes vân vân để cho nó nó bass qua.
[âm nhạc]
Còn cái ông 2.0 này nó lại chuyển qua
tính năng khác rồi mọi người. Đây nó
chuyển qua là mình vô cái phần setting
sao giờ bấm vào setting
không được đây.
Ô treo luôn rồi.
Đại khái là hồi nãy băng đầu tiên mình
có chia sẻ với cả nhà đó thì mình vào
trong cái phần setting mình chọn là full
machine ha. Rồi mình ở dưới là mình chọn
onway ship. Thì như vậy thì mọi người sẽ
bỏ đi được cái công đoạn là nó sẽ hỏi
mình. Còn mà mọi người chỗ cái phần full
machine á [âm nhạc] mà mọi người chọn là
cái tục pô. chọn cái phần tục pô là nó
sẽ không đụng luôn, không hổi luôn và nó
cho chạy tuốt luốt luôn. Nó cho chạy
tuốt luốt luôn, chạy mút mùa luôn. Đó
nếu như mọi người can đảm, mọi người
không muốn xem lại thì mọi người để cho
nó tự động thực thi [âm nhạc] thì mọi
người chọn cái phần thuộc pô ở trong đó
nó có quên đen cảnh báo ở trong cái phần
nội dung bên đó được không cả nhà? À
cũng phải nói thêm á là trong cái
a cái gì ta? Cái
tự nhiên [âm nhạc] hồi nãy mình đang nói
về cái vấn đề là
cái này nhưng mà giờ cái máy tự nhiên nó
bị bị đơ đơ chỗ này ta.
Có nghĩa là trong cái bản cập nhật mới
nhất của Google Anti Gravity 2.0 này
nha. Bản cập nhật mới nhất luôn. Ngay
tại thời điểm mọi người chọn cái project
để mọi người làm á nó sẽ hỏi mọi người
luôn 2.0 này nó sẽ hỏi luôn là bạn có
muốn chọn Full Machine hay không hay là
bạn chọn TPO là nghĩa là lúc này mình
cho nó chạy thoải mái [âm nhạc] đó. Hay
là bạn phải review lại, bạn phải chờ tôi
hỏi lại, bạn phải chờ tôi confirm.
[âm nhạc]
Thì nếu như anh chị dùng nhiều thì anh
chị sẽ thấy là nó có tính năng đó là chỗ
mà ở đây nè. Bây giờ cái máy mình không
biết là mọi người còn thấy hay không á.
Tại những chỗ này nó bị treo. Lúc mình
chọn vô trong cái [âm nhạc] new project
là mình chọn folder xong lập tức nó sẽ
hỏi mình liền là chọn
[âm nhạc] full machine hay là chọn to.
Đó nó sẽ có ba sự lựa chọn. Thì nếu như
mình chọn ở đó thì không cần thiết phải
vào chọn setting nữa. Thì đó là cái phần
để mọi người lưu ý thôi. Rồi thì cái
phần chia sẻ của mình trong tối hôm nay
chắc có chỉ để cho mọi người có thêm một
cái quyết định là nên làm như thế nào
với công cụ Anti Gravity 2.0 và dùng
Anti Gravity Ider. Ok, chắc có lẽ phần
trình bày của Minh chỉ đến đây thôi. Còn
ngoài ra thì Minh cũng muốn chia sẻ thêm
lắm nhưng mà máy của Minh giờ tạm thời
nó bị đơ rồi mọi người. Thì bây giờ tạm
thời mình giao lưu đi. Ai đặt câu hỏi
[âm nhạc] thì nếu mình biết cái gì mình
sẽ trả lời.
À không biết anh chị có ai có câu hỏi gì
mình cứ đặt câu hỏi đi mọi người.
Mình tạm thời top
share xíu.
Ok anh Vũ ơi, không biết là hôm trước
anh Vũ có bị vướng gì không anh Vũ mà.
Chào anh Minh. Đầu tiên là hết sức cảm
ơn anh Minh. Cái chia sẻ hôm nay nó tuy
[khịt mũi] thời gian nó cũng ngắn khoảng
một tiếng đồng hồ nhưng mà nó thật là
rất chất lượng và nó cũng có như trước
mình cũng có chat với Minh á là cũng
giải tỏa được một số cái băng văn về cái
sự khác biệt.
Thì chắc là mình sẽ bắt đầu mình thử
luôn cái giấ công này.
>> Mình có một số cái thắc mắc và cũng cái
phần cuối của mình cũng cũng giải thích
được một phần tức là mình vẫn có thể
mình dùng song song được cái một cách
linh hoạt. Những cái nào đó mình đã quen
thuộc thì vẫn tiếp tục dùng cái bản ID
được đúng không? [âm nhạc]
>> Dạ đúng.
>> Nhưng mà mình có nghe là cái lúc đầu mới
ra cái ID mà gắn với 2.0 này thì nó c có
một số cái lỗi lạc vặt thì mình không
biết là các bảng cập nhật mới riêng
riêng riêng đối với thôi nha. thì nó có
đã ổn định hoàn toàn chưa? Tại vì mình
vẫn đang xài cái bản 1.23 thì mình thấy
bản đó cực kỳ là nó ổn. Thì mình cũng
cũng đang lo ngại là khi mình chuyển qua
mình tiếp tục xài [âm nhạc] idea thì
liệu cái cái bản ID mới v gắn với ai nó
đã thật sự là ổn định chưa? Đó là câu
câu hỏi thứ nhất của mình. Thì thứ hai
là những cái attention á thì đúng là nó
nó rất là là phong phú. Thì đặc biệt là
mình đang cách cách làm của mình là mình
dùng cả cái codex và cái clos ngay trong
cái luôn. Thì với cái liệu anh Minh có
một cái practice nào để mình kết hợp cả
việc đó, cả tận dụng cả hai cái cái cái
mod model đó với cái 2.0 này hay không?
Hay là đã chọn 2.0 rồi thì mình phải hy
sinh hy sinh cái việc dùng một lúc đồng
thời nhiều cái model đó.
Thì mình tạm thời mình có hai câu hỏi đó
thì dạ
>> nh minh dùm.
>> Dạ. Rồi em ok cái phần đầu [âm nhạc]
tiên nhá. Cái phần đầu tiên là cái phần
mà anh đang sử dụng vẫn là Google à
antiravity I cũ hả anh?
À bản cũ.
>> Dạ thật ra nhá đến thời điểm này á theo
cá nhân em là em cứ có bản cập nhật mới
là em sẽ cập nhật.
Cứ có bản cập nhật mới là em sẽ cập
nhật. Có thể nha, có thể đâu đó là mọi
người sẽ thấy nó bị lỗi nhưng với trường
hợp của em thì em sử dụng. Đến hiện tại
thì em không thấy [âm nhạc] nó lỗi. Và
cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai là để chắc ăn
á trước khi anh chuyển sang cái việc cập
nhật mình để mình chắc cứu á thì anh yêu
cầu nó là backup cái data lại kể cả luôn
backup cái phần mà conversation hay là
cup backup toàn diện tùy theo cách mình
[âm nhạc] bình thường mình backup như
thế nào đó là để mình mình lưu ý trước
cái phần đó tránh trường hợp mà khi mà
nâng cấp xong rồi nó có những cái sửa
đổi bổ sung mà mình quay trở lại không
được á thì mình sẽ phục [âm nhạc] hồi
lại. Thì em cũng lâu lâu em sẽ làm cái
phần đó em backup lại em lưu lại lên
trên cái ổ hoặc Google [âm nhạc] Drive
á. Đó đó là cái phần em chuyển giao. Còn
à không biết là nãy hình như là trong
cái phần câu hỏi đầu của anh nó có cũng
có liên quan đến cái phần
2.0 đúng không anh ạ?
>> Cái câu hỏi hai của mình chứ hả?
Mình chỉ nói về cái tính ổn định thôi.
Còn câu hai của mình là làm sao mà dùng
2.0 mà có thể tận dụng được thêm những
cái mô hình dùng cái attention ví dụ như
codes code hay là cloud code như là
chấm.
>> Ừ. Dạ. Thì cái này nhá à em cũng trả lời
thêm với trường hợp này nhá. Thực tế ra
anh hình dung chỗ này. Bản thân cái
model [âm nhạc] 2.0, antiravity 2.0 á,
ông Google ổng build ra ổng tách riêng
ra là ổng đã có mục đích rồi. Ổng đã có
mục đích rồi. Nghĩa [âm nhạc] là cái này
chuyên về Asian first là chuyên về cái
việc thực thi và để cho tính đơn giản là
mọi người chỉ là vào là gõ câu lệnh vào
là làm nó tự động đi thực thient first.
Đó đúng nghĩa là nó được cái từ gọi là
first. Như vậy thì quay lại nếu như mà
mình bảo là để dùng cái cách nào tích
hợp vào thì [âm nhạc] chỉ có quay trở về
sử dụng lại cái công cụ Google Anti
Gravity Ide truyền thống thôi. Thì lúc
này là mình mới tận dụng được cái
[âm nhạc] codex và cái clot clot code
đúng không? Anh đang sử dụng clot code
bên đó. Dạ. Dạ.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Dạ. Đó thì em cũng giữ sử dụng là bên đó
cái nền tảng đó. Thì kiểu như vậy thì
lúc này ông Google ông đã tách ra rồi
anh. Cho nên mục đích mà mình kêu mình
[âm nhạc] lại đưa vào chung á thì nó rất
là khó.
Đó cho nên thôi mình cứ sử dụng code de
với lại cloud code ở bên ID đi anh. À
bên đó em thấy nó vẫn ổn mà.
Chị cho mình hỏi kỹ hơn, tức là nếu mà
dùng song song như lúc nãy cái ví dụ của
anh Minh á
>> là mình mình chạy bằng cái multiagent
trong cái cái agent này thì mình qua bên
kia mình sẽ theo dõi được cái việc nó
tạo nó tạo những cái file trong kia chia
bình thường đúng không?
Đúng rồi anh. Anh sẽ thấy của
>> đúng đúng anh sẽ thấy được. Nhưng mà
trong cái lúc mà giữa cái ngày nó đang
thao tác
à 2.0 đang thao tác [âm nhạc] thì anh cố
gắng ở bên kia anh chỉ xem thôi. Anh
đừng anh đừng thao tác gì cả. Anh đừng
[âm nhạc] yêu cầu câu lệnh gì cả. Tại vì
đã có lần nhá. Đã có lần em thử à em tạo
ra cái chương trình mà em đào tạo đó.
Kiểu kiểu như vậy thì trong cái quá
trình em kêu bên này nó làm xong em lại
đứng cái bên cái nền tảng giống như nãy
em mở song song cho mọi người thấy á em
lại kêu bên đó nó chỉnh sửa nội dung
nhưng em quên rằng là backup sau lưu lại
cái nội dung gốc nội dung gốc [âm nhạc]
à thì như vậy thì cái ông này ổng làm
xong ổ sửa đổi ổng thay đổi ổ thay đổi
luôn cái nội dung gốc của mình đó là lúc
đó nó thay đổi về vải chất rồi có nghĩa
là lúc này mình mới nhận ra là tại một
thời điểm đó có thể làm được
cùng một thư mục cùng một cái
và chưa kể nếu mà anh cho anh làm việc
song song nữa như vậy thì nó cũng
[âm nhạc] bị loạn ở trong cái vấn đề
giống như một file Excel mà mình share
ra mọi người cùng dùng chung á.
Đó [hắng giọng]
túc
>> hỏi cho mình hỏi luôn là liệu mình có
thể dừng tạm dừng cái Asient
multiagent đó lại rồi mình sửa bên kia
và mình yêu cầu nó là đọc lại cái trạng
thái cái bên kia đã sửa được không? Tại
vì thường ví dụ mình dùng nhiều nhiều
cái mô hình ngay trong mình cũng hay làm
như vậy. Tức là mình thấy một thằng đi
chà hướng rồi mình mình s
>> Đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng. Có anh à
có nghĩa là với cái việc này thì lúc này
đòi hỏi anh phải là người giống như hồi
nãy anh để ý cái phần của em em build ra
một cái trang web đúng không ạ? Đến thời
điểm này nó vẫn chưa dạy xong thì em
chưa biết là có những cái tác nhân nào
có nghĩa là có những cái anh nhân viên
nào còn bên trong á ảnh còn đang cậm cụi
ảnh đi làm việc ở bên trong á mà
[âm nhạc] mình không biết. Thì lúc này
mình phải chịu khó mình đi vô mình xem
và mình stop ảnh. Thì có những lần em đã
phải stop sau đó em lại đi ra bên ngoài
em rà hết những cái phần kia nó tới đâu.
Em lại quay trở lại em lại chỉ định luôn
em nói là tiếp tục cái Asient 4 cho tao
thì lúc này nó mới tái khởi động tiếp
cái Aent 4. Vậy thôi thì cũng chỉ là
bằng thao tác câu lệnh thôi anh. Dạ hoàn
toàn được. Ở dưới trong [âm nhạc] đó
mình sẽ bấm có phần stop.
Ok rồi. Không biết là anh
>> các anh chị khác hỏi từ.
>> Dạ. Dạ.
>> Rồi có anh anh anh anh em nào có câu hỏi
có đặt câu hỏi thì cứ đặt câu hỏi ha.
Tối hôm nay thì mình chỉ là giao lưu với
nhau thôi mọi người. Mọi người bật mic
luôn cho nó vui.
Hồi nãy em thấy Giang đang có một cái
câu gì ở Giang ơi?
Em tự hỏi [âm nhạc]
>> em chào anh Ninh và chào tất cả mọi
người. Thực ra thì lúc mà em chuyển sang
trang dùng cái 2.0 ấy thì một trongng
câu hỏi của em [âm nhạc] chính là tại
sao mà em không có cách nào em có thể mở
được cái folder giống như bên IDE để mở
ra xem là các cái file kinh doanh như
thế nào để kiểm soát. Thế thì hôm nay
thì mình biết được rằng là có thể là cái
2.0 đấy là không thể mở được thì mình sẽ
phải chấp nhận bằng cách là mở song
[âm nhạc] song. Và cũng tiếp với câu hỏi
của các anh lúc nãy thì em nghĩ rằng là
em muốn hỏi là nếu như mà mình chạy song
song như vậy, mình đang chạy multi mà
mình chạy và nó sinh ra file mà mình sửa
thêm ID thì nó sẽ bị [âm nhạc] loạn.
Nhưng nếu như trong trường hợp mà mình
đọc cái file sinh ra bên IDM mình biết
là nó có vấn đề rồi. Mình dừng cái file
chạy ở ở bên 2.0 lại [âm nhạc] và mình
chạy cái câu lệnh mình sửa ở bên IDE thì
nó có gây ra cái vấn đề mà nó bị kiểu
như nó bị rối loạn đầu óc của cái con
đấy không? Đấy em có cái câu hỏi là như
thế.
Ừ. Em em em nói lại anh chưa hình dung
cái chỗ em vừa nói [âm nhạc] cái chỗ mà
rối là cái chỗ idea á hả?
>> Ừ. Lúc nãy anh có trả lời là khi mà
[âm nhạc] anh cho nó chạy song song thì
anh có khuyến cáo rằng là mình nhìn thấy
cái file bên [âm nhạc] IDE đấy là nó
sinh ra rồi nhưng mình hãy xem mà đừng
sửa đúng không?
Đúng
>> bởi vì là không [âm nhạc] thì nó sẽ bị
là nó giống như kiểu là nó sẽ bị vừa sửa
của mình vừa viết ra thì có một cái khác
nó trền [âm nhạc] vào ấy. Thế vậy thì
đấy là vì nó chạy song song. Thế nhưng
ví dụ như khi mà chạy một cái thì em
phát hiện ra là à nó sinh ra [âm nhạc]
cái sản phẩm sinh ra nó chưa đảm bảo nhu
cầu thì như vậy là cái con kia nó chưa
làm được hiệu quả. thì em có thể dừng
cái con dừng cái bên 2.0 lại và đồng
thời là em sửa ở lúc này em mới sửa ở
bên IDE
>> để mà thì có được hay không và nó có bị
nó có bị cái tình trạng giống như cái
lúc mà mình chạy song song [âm nhạc]
không hay là làm như thế thì sẽ ổn hơn
ạ. Đấy em đang c như thế
>> à. Ok anh trả lời luôn cái phần này.
Thực ra á là cái này cũng đã anh đã từng
làm rồi.
Cũng quay lại cái câu chuyện có nghĩa là
ở bên 2.0 khi nó chạy multiaent á thì nó
tạo ra mình cho mình nguyên [âm nhạc]
một mình hiểu là nguyên một cái khung
nha. Nó tạo ra cho mình chỉ tích tắc
thôi. Với cái câu lệnh một vài cái câu
lệnh như hồi [âm nhạc] nãy mình đang làm
á Multient hay là Teamwork Review á nó
cho mình nguyên một cái khung luôn một
cái sườn của một cái ngôi [âm nhạc] nhà
luôn. Nhưng mà đôi khi ở bên trong cái
phần cấu kiện ở bên trong á, những cái
phòng vân vân thì nó lại chưa có hoàn
chỉnh. [âm nhạc] Thì lúc này mình yêu
cầu nó phải điều chỉnh lại thì mình lại
mang qua bên cái Google Antiraity Ider á
để [âm nhạc] nó điều chỉnh hoàn toàn
bình thường. À và lúc này ở bên cái ông
mà
2.0 á thì nó làm á thì mình nhưng mà
mình cũng phải mình cũng phải lưu
[âm nhạc] lưu ý là làm gì thì làm. Do
bản chất hai cái này khi nó đã tách ra,
nó không còn sở hữu chung một cái đường
dẫn nữa. À nó trước đây nó chung một cái
đường dẫn nghĩa là Asian Manager. Nó sử
[âm nhạc] dụng chung một cái cái góc là
antiravity germin trong cái đường dẫn á
nó cũng bằng đường dựng góc nhưng bây
giờ nó đã tách ra cho nên cái mình hiểu
cơ bản là về cái não át có sự khác biệt.
Vậy thì quay lại cái bài toán này, lúc
mà mình yêu cầu mình chỉnh sửa ở bên cái
phần ID á thì cũng cần phải yêu cầu là
[âm nhạc] qua bên 2.0 á mình phải nói để
cho nó hình dung. Có nghĩa là à tao vừa
chỉnh sửa lại cái nội dung của cái này
cái kia [âm nhạc] mày hãy cập nhật lại
đi được không ạ? Em em hình dung được.
Có nghĩa là tao vừa chỉnh sửa ở bên nền
tảng A, nền tảng B gì đó mình nói hoặc
là tao chỉnh sửa bằng tay thì mày hãy
cập nhật lại để mày hiểu được cách tao
vừa làm. Chứ mình đừng có sửa rồi mà
mình cứ im ỉm imỉm mà mình không nói đó.
Thì lúc này nó hình dung là nó vẫn làm
nhưng mà trong não của nó là nó hình
dung đó là cái công thức của nó. Và đến
khi cần à thì chính anh cũng đã bị rồi
nha. Đến khi cần mình yêu cầu nó là tiếp
tục làm cái công việc bên kia đi. Nhưng
mà lúc này nó trong não của nó. trong
não của nó là nó vẫn đang nhớ là cái quy
trình hay là cách làm á là từ đầu đến
giờ là tôi vẫn là như vậy thôi. Anh đâu
có nói với tôi là cập nhật gì đâu mà.
Cho nên lại tiếp tục nó đi trong cái
phần đếp của nó là nó đi tiếp. Nó đi
tiếp và nó làm thì đâm ra nó vẫn sai. Từ
sai đ nó vẫn dẫn đến sai. Nó chưa hoàn
chỉnh chưa [âm nhạc] hoàn hảo chứ cũng
không hẳn gọi là sai. Mà do cái hoàn
chỉnh hoàn hảo để mình lại đi cập nhật
bên IDER á mình lại không nói cho nó. Đó
thì cái này là mình phải tương tác song
song thôi. Mình vừa làm ở bên này vừa
làm bên kia thì mình phải chịu khó.
>> Vâng ạ. [âm nhạc] Nhiều rồi. Cảm ơn anh.
>> Ok.
Hôm trước chị Hiền có một câu hỏi không
biết trên kia thì chị Hiền đã về thử cho
chị Hiền ơi
ở đây còn
[âm nhạc] à chị nói không được. Dạ rồi.
Ok. Còn anh anh em nào ở đây có câu hỏi
không? Chiều nay bắt đầu anh Chung là
bắt đầu đã thử cái tính năng multiasent
trên 2.0 rồi đúng không anh Trung ơi?
À Minh hy vọng nhé. Kịp [âm nhạc] thì
qua tuần sau mình sẽ có buổi Zoom để
chia sẻ về cái cách làm. Ở đây là mình
sẽ mời thêm một bạn, [âm nhạc] hai bạn
nữa chứ không phải chỉ mình. Hôm đó bạn
cũng hôm nay là có bạn đó hiện đang ngồi
đây để nói về cái cách mà dùng
antiravity.
Cái cách mà antiravity sẽ build ra app
làm build ra app nhé build [âm nhạc]
cách ăn dùng antiity 2.0 không để build
up làm video à đó thì à làm video
YouTube
mọi người không biết có ai ở đây có hứng
thú về cách đó hay không nhé nhưng mà
đợi mọi người co bức tranh tổng quan
build app á
anh trình anh còn đang nợ tôi một cái
cái buổi workshop nha anh trình mọi
người đang chờ anh dữ lắm luôn á
nghiên cứu rồi
>> à chiều nay mới có người hỏi đó anh
Trình ơi. Chiều nay mới có người hỏi cái
cái của anh trình cái skill mà notebook
cộng với MT Gravity rồi khi [âm nhạc]
nào anh Minh ơi?
À ok không sao anh nói vui anh Trình ơi
thì các anh cứ sắp xếp thì trong trường
hợp mà có gì thì anh cứ báo thì anh mình
sẽ online zom thôi.
Rồi ok còn có anh em nào có câu hỏi gì
nữa không ạ?
Tối hôm nay để mọi người phải chờ đợi
hơi lâu, mất khoảng 10 15 phút đầu rồi.
>> Ủa cho mình hỏi cái bên cái 2.0 á, rồi
mấy cái ví dụ như là
mấy cái skill mà nó nằm bên ID là nó vẫn
xài được đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi anh anh Trình. Nhưng mà có một
cái vậy nè chị Hiền đợi em tí [âm nhạc]
xíu em.
Bên cái
skill bên kia á là nếu như mình đang ở
cái đường dẫn nha, mình để ý rồi là nó
có hai cái đường dẫn lúc này nó đặt ở
hai cái đường dẫn khác nhau. À nó có hai
cái đường dẫn mà nó hay bị lẫn lộn. Rồi
cái ông 2.0 nhiều khi ổng không thấy thì
nó đọc vô thì [âm nhạc] nó lại chưa nhận
diện được á. Thì lúc này một là mình à
mình phải giống như mình phải sao lưu á
từ cái bộ bên kia mình đẩy qua thêm bên
này. Còn không là mình phải chỉ đường
dẫn cho nó. À bắt ch bình hình dung kịp
không? Giống như là việc mình lấy skill
về mình để cho D vậy đó. Rồi mình chỉ
đường dẫn cho nó thôi.
>> Ok. Ok.
>> Thì lúc này mình cũng chỉ đường dẫn cho
nó là nó đọc được thôi.
Nó vẫn sử dụng bình thường hết bác
trình. Dạ. Rồi à trường hợp chị Hiền á
thì
bản Pro mà vẫn có team TeamW hả? Đến
thời điểm hiện tại là em không biết nhá.
Có thể là do em đang cập nhật muộn hoặc
là em không cập nhật mới nhưng mà ở thời
điểm mà cách đây khoảng hai tuần ba tuần
ờ khi mà làm á thì mọi người lên trên
cái
ok rồi vậy là có bản team web [âm nhạc]
vậy là nó có cập nhật cho mọi người cái
bảng này rồi đó mọi người thử dùng đi
ha còn cái [âm nhạc] câu lệnh mà involve
sub agent với lại define agent á thì cái
này là cái mà nó nằm sâu vào cái lỗi ở
bên trong.
À chị nói là mình không thấy Asian
[âm nhạc] này. Thật ra nó không phải là
ừ cái tên của cái con Asian bình thường
mà chị hiểu nó được dùng cái từ define
là [âm nhạc] để định nghĩa nha. Define
là dùng để định nghĩa. Còn cái con
invagent [âm nhạc] là cái đó dùng để tạo
ra à thiết kế ra theo mình nhớ [âm nhạc]
là như vậy. À thì như vậy thì lúc này á
bản thân mình chỉ là người gõ cái câu
lệnh bình thường [âm nhạc] thì lúc này
nó sẽ tự đi gọi cái involve đó lên.
Giống như hồi nãy mình có chia sẻ là gì
ạ? À ông CEO ổng giao việc xuống
[âm nhạc] cho ông trưởng phòng thì chắc
chắn trưởng phòng thì phải có lính chứ
đúng không? À đó thì trong ông chủ phòng
ổng sẽ có
hai ba người lúm và ổng giao cái việc đó
xuống cho ở bên dưới [âm nhạc] thì lúc
này nó tự động nó đi gọi cái lệnh
involve subent để nó phân bổ cái công
việc đó ra. Và dĩ nhiên cái này
[âm nhạc] nó được bốc tách nếu mà chị
ngồi đào sâu vào bên trong. Tại vì hôm
đó mình ngồi mình phải nói luôn là mình
ngồi đến tận phia mình cũng phải mất hai
ngày để chỉ vọc vote agent thôi. Và hôm
đó mình còn gọi điện cho bạn Thủy nữa. Ở
đây đang có Thủy ngồi ở đây mình có nói
về cái cái involve và cái define này và
chia sẻ thì chị yêu cầu nó là cái
involve subagent này nó làm cái gì chị
hỏi nó thì chị sẽ thấy nó rất là rõ cái
cách nó làm. Và bình thường khi mà mình
chỉ giao việc cho nó và mình nói là tạo
ra cho tôi là năm sub asent [âm nhạc]
hay là tự phân bổ công việc như thế nào
chạy multision thì lúc này nó tự động nó
gọi cái lệnh involve nó lên đôi khi mình
thấy và đôi khi mình không thấy.
À cái phần flash 2 á chị thật ra mình
hình dung như vậy à tại sao mà nói là
không cần model của clot không phải mà
mình hình dung á là cái flash 2 lúc này
nhá về cái [âm nhạc] cota của flash 2
3.5 á được ra mắt gần đây sau cái sự
kiện mà Google IO 2026 vừa rồi á
[âm nhạc] thì Google có công bố ra cái
phiên bản 3.5 năm 3.5 thì đến thời điểm
này theo mình theo mình thì nó vẫn dùng
khá là ổn đối với một số cái tác vụ và
nhất là những cái tác vụ mà cần có cái
đầu mục mà [âm nhạc]
giống như hồi nãy mình nói á nó cầm cầm
mà nó tốn nhiều cota được không ạ? Tốn
nhiều cota tại vì khi mà mình chạy mà đa
nhiệm tạo ra luôn nguyên một cái hệ sinh
[âm nhạc] tái lớn tạo ra một cái ứng
dụng web app lớn tạo ra một cái gì đó
thì nó tốn rất nhiều cô cô ta. Vậy
[âm nhạc] thì lúc này mình đang sử dụng
là email mà bản đặc biệt mà bản pro nữa
nhá. Thì cái lượt quota mình nó sẽ có
hạn chế mà mình lại mang cái con clock
ra để sử dụng thì nó cực kỳ gọi là tốn
kém. Phải nói luôn [âm nhạc] nó cực kỳ
tốn kém. Cho nên á là lúc này chính ông
ông ông ông ông ông Google ổng ổng
recommend luôn là nên dùng cái chức năng
là à flat.
Dạ nên dùng [âm nhạc] flash 3.5 và để
cho nó cải tiếng thì mình dùng thêm chữ
hai thì để cho nó thông minh hơn thôi.
Đó và mình sử dụng bữa giờ thì cái phần
flash nó cũng khá nhiều nhưng mà đúng là
có những cái bài toán mình dùng 3.5
không giải quyết được mình buộc
[âm nhạc]
mình phải dùng
>> không chơi nữa.
>> Đó thì đại cái là mình dùng mình mình
tùy thời điểm tùy lúc mà mình sẽ ứng
dụng mình chọn cái model nào đó chị chị
Hiền ơi. Dạ.
À
ok. À không biết là còn có anh chị em
nào có câu hỏi nữa không ạ?
Cũng khá lâu rồi. Anh Hùng ơi, dạo này
lâu quá không gặp anh Hùng. Anh Nguyễn
Trung Hùng.
Ok em ở đi. Thủ
>> ấy là hôm trước anh có nói
khi mình cài [âm nhạc] cái ID
như em thì em đã lỡ cập nhật cái 2.0
rồi. Vậy thì khi [âm nhạc] mình cài cái
ID thì dạo gần đây anh thấy nó còn mất
dữ liệu hay là phải back cup trước khi
cài về.
>> À
>> nó an toàn được không anh? Nó an toàn
không bây giờ?
Thật ra cái việc mà an toàn hay không á
thì trước cái việc mà mình làm mới thì
cũng nên backup sau lưu ra là chắc chắn
nhất. À mình nên tự phòng ngừa trước khi
mà mình đến ấy ha mà mình đến cái việc
mà đã là chuyện đã lỡ rồi thì mới đi hỏi
chữa trị thì lúc đó cũng muộn rồi. Nhiều
khi lúc đó là hỏi là tại ông Minh không
tư vấn.
>> Nhưng mà hình như
nếu mà em có bắt cấp ra rồi trước em có
tải về thì nó vẫn bị trống anh giống như
cái mới hoàn toàn.
thì làm sao lôi [âm nhạc] ngược trở lại
cho nó đồng bộ vào trong cái idea
>> à không bây giờ nhá mình hình dung là
cái đường dẫn của 2.0 nó đã khác với
đường dẫn của bảng ID cho nên cái luồng
chat của bên này và luồng chat của bên
kia mình không thể đồng bộ được.
À anh [âm nhạc] đang nói là em khi em
cài á để tránh cái sự cố thì mình cài
2.0 mình backup cái luồng dữ liệu của
2.0 ra sau đó là mình mới cài cái bản ID
lên.
Em hình dung được không?
>> Thì em làm vậy đó. Em có làm vậy đó
[âm nhạc] chứ. Em không có lấy cái luồng
mới của 2.0 đâu. Luồng cũ của ID á.
>> Ừ. Thật ra á là
>> nhưng mà khi cài về rồi thì nó trống tức
làm sao nó có thể khớp vào khi [âm nhạc]
cài về ha.
>> Không bây giờ nó đã ngay từ thời điểm
đầu. Ngay từ thời điểm đầu là mình đã bị
mất rồi mà
đúng không?
Ngay từ cái lúc mà sau khi mà mọi người
bị chuyển giao nó tách cái ID và 2.0 ra
là mọi người tự nhiên bị đảo qua 2.0 và
đảo qua cái ID. Là tại thời điểm đó mọi
người bản thân anh anh cũng bị mất cái
luồng dữ [âm nhạc] liệu ở bên bên bên
kia một phần. Tới thời điểm này có những
cái cũng bị mất mà nhưng mà nó map qua
bên 2.0 rồi. Thì bây giờ được đơn giản
nhất là em lấy cái dữ liệu mà à chat đó.
á em copy em có thể bỏ qua bên bên bên
bên kia được.
Nó có cái đường dẫn công
>> đúng rồi. Còn không thì mình yêu cầu
luôn.
>> Ví dụ như nguyên cái thư nguyên cái thư
mục mà khi mình bắt cấp ra lại á mình
lấy nguyên [âm nhạc] cái đó mình bỏ vô
lại cho nó để cho nó học lại hết thôi.
>> Mình tốt nhất
>> mình yêu cầu nhá. Mình yêu cầu nhá. Mình
chỉ đường dẫn cho đó nguyên cái thư mục
makeup đó mình chỉ đường dẫn vô là
[âm nhạc] cái đây là thư mục makeup nè.
Bạn hãy đọc nó đi.
>> Rồi ok. Dạ.
>> Đó thì cái này thì anh cũng hôm trước
anh làm vậy thôi là mình đưa cho đường
dẫn nó backup rồi mình chưa yêu cầu nó
đọc đi.
Giờ nó biết.
>> Dạ. Cảm ơn anh.
>> Ok. Chào anh Hùng.
>> Chào anh Minh nhá.
>> Lâu quá lâu quá.
>> Wow. Em lâu quá ít ít vào ít sờ mó đến
món này
>> à.
Vậy thì hôm nay cơn gió nào đưa anh đến
đây đây?
Hôm nay á, hôm nay Thánh Minh chia sẻ
trên nhóm
anti 2.0 bảo thế mình trễ nhiều quá rồi
mấy tháng rồi không không dùng đến vào
cập nhập xem đến đoàn nào rồi.
>> À
>> trước thì cò còn có cái dự án làm cái
app kia
>> nhưng mà nhưng mà gì gần đây không làm
nữa hả anh?
>> Gần đây không làm nữa
>> à. Ok.
tưởng đâu [âm nhạc] có cái phần nào hay
thì chia sẻ với mọi người.
>> Vâng. [tiếng cười] Nó bây giờ mới thi
thoảng vào cầm nhập lại thôi. Không tụt
hậu quá.
>> Vâng. Ở đây [âm nhạc] ở đây sẽ có những
anh chị á là cao tay ấn hơn Minh rất là
nhiều nhưng mà tại vì mọi người cũng
ngại không có đặt câu hỏi cũng không có
chia sẻ thôi chứ còn Minh thì Minh chỉ
sử dụng gần như là trung thành với công
cụ Google Anti Gravity
với CODEX. Còn bản thân mình á thì lại
không có tiền để mình nuôi thêm cái ông
ông clot. Hôm bữa mình có nuôi được 2
tháng rồi mình cho nó bay màu luôn rồi.
>> Nuôi nuôi tốn kép quá.
>> Ok rồi. Anh Trung ơi, hồi chiều anh
Trung chạy cái Mion sau là anh Trung
thấy anh Bill cái app ra kế toán hay
quá. Anh Trung
không biết anh Trung còn có online không
ta?
Ờ ở đây nhé. [âm nhạc]
Mình có vừa bây giờ mình mới vừa thấy
cái người bạn mình đó là anh Bảo ha. À
lần tới tuần [âm nhạc] sau mình sẽ mời
Bảo với lại Thủy chia sẻ về cái cách làm
ứng dụng công cụ Anti Gravity 2.0 này
[âm nhạc] để build app làm video
à cho YouTube. Và cái cách làm này là sẽ
tự động theo kiểu gọi là bán content.
Không biết là nếu như anh [âm nhạc] chị
ở đây có những người làm về YouTube hoặc
là nghe về YouTube á thì mới hiểu cái từ
bán content á là cách để làm sao tự
[âm nhạc] động lên lấy video cắt mỗi
đoạn video đó là 5 giây rồi ghép lại như
thế nào vân vân. Đó thì lúc này anti
hoàn toàn có thể làm được việc đó nha
mọi người. [âm nhạc] Lấy link về tự động
cắt thì sáng nay có nói sơ lược với anh
anh Trình đó
thì cái FFB á nó là một trong những công
cụ rất là mạnh ha. Nó có thể chích xúc
audio rồi có thể cắt ghép [âm nhạc] cái
thằng
ultatiy này nó sẽ kết nối với cái phần
đó. Được chưa ạ? Thì ở đây nó còn hơn
cái thế nữa là nó buill thành một cái
app lớn luôn là anh Bảo với lại bạn
Thủy. Ở đây là hai người bạn của mình đã
làm đến cái phần đó luôn rồi. Và hiện
nay đang a đang đến một cái giai đoạn
khác rồi. Mọi người đã build ra những
cái app mà làm cho bên nền tảng YouTube.
Đó thì đây là phần mình chia sẻ thêm để
hẹn mọi người qua tuần. Nếu sắp xếp được
thì mình sẽ [âm nhạc]
thông báo cho mọi người ha. Rồi như vậy
thì ở trong này còn anh chị nào mà có
câu hỏi gì cho cái buổi tối hôm nay
không? Tại vì cái buổi zom của mình nó
cũng đã đi qua gần 2 tiếng rồi và thời
gian thì cũng mình nghĩ là sắp hết rồi
mọi người ạ.
Giang còn câu hỏi gì không em ơi? Bữa
giờ đi ra đảo nhiều quá rồi không có có
cập nhật phải không?
Nghe nói ra đảo nghe [âm nhạc] ghê quá.
>> Đợn này về bờ em sẽ cập nhật lại từ đầu.
Cập nhật đi. À lâu quá rồi nó nâng cấp
nó đi quá xa rồi.
À
có một cái mình [âm nhạc] định chia sẻ
thêm nhưng mà nó cũng này là mình nói
thêm thôi. Ở đây chắc có lẽ nhiều anh
chị đang sử dụng anti giống mình nhưng
cũng có nhiều anh chị là kết hợp giống
như nãy anh Vũ á là sẽ sử dụng luôn cả
clot codex. Có lẽ là anh anh Vũ làm bên
[âm nhạc] rất là nhiều lĩnh vực nên sử
dụng đa đa công cụ.
Thì theo Minh á đến hồi tối hôm qua
à Minh có ngồi với một nhóm nữa à bên
bên bên bên bên bên một nhóm khác thì họ
chia sẻ [âm nhạc] về cách phân tích dữ
liệu. Phân tích dữ liệu cực kỳ chuyên
sâu. À cái buổi tối hôm qua mình cảm
thấy rất là hứng thú nha. Lượng dữ liệu
khoảng 540.000
vòng.
540.000 vòng à. làm sao để phân tích cái
lượng dữ liệu lớn đó thì trước giờ nói
thật ra bản thân mình mình chỉ biết có
thể là bốc tách giống như vừa rồi mình
bốc tách khối lượng à mà mình có xe trên
cộng đồng bốc tách khối lượng mình lấy
[âm nhạc] ra như thế nào rồi dùng skill
như thế nào để bốc tách cái đó ra tuy
nhiên đến ngày hồi tối hôm qua khi mình
ngồi rồi mình mới thấy là cái công cụ
[âm nhạc] clot á thực sự nó có cái điểm
mạnh riêng của nó so với cái công cụ
anti gravity như thế nào à tại vì mình
cũng ít dùng những cái công cụ clot đó
nên mình không rõ là cái sức [âm nhạc]
mạnh của nó. À đó cái đó có cũng phải
nói thật. Tuy nhiên cũng nó quay trở về
một cái bài toán căn cơ thôi mọi người
và tùy vào tính chất công việc của mọi
người nữa. Thì như mình á đến thời điểm
hiện tại lúc ban đầu mình chia sẻ là mọi
người thấy á mình đã có thể [âm nhạc]
làm ra một cái trang web để phục vụ cho
công việc của mình. Hay [âm nhạc] sáng
nay à ở đây có ai biết cái trang web của
anh Hải Trình chưa ạ? Hải trình.org. Thì
anh Hải Trình chắc chắn sẽ [âm nhạc]
cũng có giữ lời hứa với mình rồi là sẽ
có một cái buổi Zoom để chia sẻ về cách
mà anh ứng dụng Anti Gravity để làm cái
trang [âm nhạc] web mà Hải Dương học của
anh kết nối với Notebook MM cực kỳ chất
lượng nha mọi người. Phải nói là cực kỳ
chất lượng luôn. Nếu mà mọi người chưa
thấy mọi người có thể vào cái trang
hiring.org [âm nhạc]
à để cho con hay là cho cháu của mình
vào trong đó để xem và học hỏi rất là
nhiều kiến thức hay bổ ích mà anh anh
Trình đã dày công ra. để vung đắp cái
trang web đó mọi người.
>> Ờ cảm ơn Minh Minh sáng giờ giới thiệu
nhiều quá bác Minh [tiếng cười]
24 chia phần 24 ch%
>> phi lợi nhuận bác Minh ơi. [tiếng cười]
>> Nói vui nói vui. Ok [âm nhạc] đó thì
mình quay lại cái câu chuyện để mình
muốn nói rằng cái gì ạ? À
tùy vào tính chất công việc mà khi mình
ứng dụng công cụ [âm nhạc] Anti Drabity
nó vẫn đủ sức để làm ra những cái trang
web cực kỳ chất [âm nhạc] lượng. Hay là
sắp tới bạn của mình là anh Bảo sẽ chia
sẻ về cái app để phục vụ cho cái việc
làm YouTube tự [âm nhạc] động hóa hoàn
toàn. Thì mọi người hình dung là cái gì
ạ? Cuối cùng là cái gì? Chúng ta ở đây á
mình đang nói là không phải là cái sức
mạnh của cái công cụ kia là mình phải
thừa nhận nó rất là mạnh. Tuy nhiên cũng
phải quay lại là cách chúng ta tận dụng
cách chúng ta tận dụng mỗi công cụ nó
như thế nào nữa. Ví dụ nhá à mọi người
đang sử dụng cái
clot rất là nhiều đúng không ạ? rồi
build ra rất là nhiều loại skill a b các
kiểu. Nhưng mọi người thấy có những lúc
khi chỉ cần minh chia sẻ về một cái
skill nào đó là mọi người thấy á là mình
vẫn làm bằng chính cái công cụ
antiravity mà thôi. [âm nhạc] Và mọi
người thấy
nó vẫn phục vụ đủ cái tính năng chứ nó
không hề bị ờ giảm chất lượng hay là như
thế này thế kia. Thì cái đó là do cái
người thực thi và do cái cái cái cách
chúng ta áp dụng cái công cụ đó như thế
nào vào trong công việc. Thì cái này là
mình chia sẻ thêm thôi mọi người. Cho
nên mình cứ đào sâu vào một công cụ để
theo Minh. [âm nhạc] Nếu như mà cái kinh
phí mình có thì mình có thể đầu tư thêm
clot thì để mình mình học đó để mình coi
được cái tính năng cao cấp của nó như
thế nào. Tại vì thầ thật sự nó quá mạnh
luôn. Theo như qua mình ngồi mình trải
nghiệm cái cách mà phân tích dữ liệu
540.000 ngàn dòng của một phá Excel thì
mình hình dung ra được cái vấn đề. Tuy
nhiên á là phải nói rằng á là để làm
được những cái việc đó thì đòi hỏi một
lượt quota và xử lý như thế nào a b các
bước còn lại công cụ này của mình nó có
mức giới hạn [âm nhạc] thì mình phải
chấp nhận thôi mọi người. Rồi thì cái
này phần chia sẻ thêm thôi. À anh trình
thì chắc chắn rồi thì trong chắc phải
trong tuần sau thôi chứ còn tuần này thì
đúng anh Trình ha.
Sao tuần sau
>> tuần sao từng sau bạn Giang là hồi nãy
có hỏi rồi đó bạn Giang ở dưới nó ấn
tượng ở dưới kìa anh anh không làm đi
bạn Giang [âm nhạc] bạn Giang vô xử lý
anh đó chừng giỡn đâu.
>> Sao lại sợ dẫm thế? [tiếng cười]
Bạn mới ở ngoài đảo ngoài đảo về đó anh.
>> Anh cũng mới đảo về
>> đó. Ô đó [tiếng cười]
>> thế vậy thì nghi có khi anh Minh mới là
người bị xử lý.
>> Cũng đi lâu giờ thấy cái 2.0 nhưng mà
cũng ngại chưa có thử.
Bây giờ sao buổi hôm nay mới dám thử.
>> [tiếng cười]
>> Thôi [âm nhạc] thôi vậy chứ
>> sợ nó sợ nó đụng vào cái project mình
đang chạy ổn á. Sợ nó
đụng vào cái nó có vấn đề gì lại mệt l.
Đúng rồi. Ờ trước tiên [âm nhạc] thì
mình cứ xem kỹ cái đó mình backup sau
lưu hết anh à anh Trình ơi. Rồi coi lại
đường dẫn thôi chứ còn thật ra á là mình
cách đây
cách đây cách đây khoảng mình không nhớ
chính xác cũng khoảng hai tuần chứ mấy.
cái trang web mà nãy mình show ra cho
mọi người xem á là cái hôm đó mình tưởng
chừng mình bị mất cái dữ liệu [âm nhạc]
à mất cái data về nhân viên và những cái
phần chấm công hay là những cái phần tại
vì [âm nhạc] khi mà làm xong á là cái
lần hôm đó là đúng là mình lần đầu tiên
làm về app và cái ông antiravity với
[âm nhạc] 2.0 này á thì mình đâu có nắm
hết được cái cách cái ngóc ngách của nó
đâu. Tự nhiên cái ôm đó
nó làm cho mình
nó nâng cấp hay là nó làm cái gì đây tự
nhiên mình quên đó mình mất sạch luôn
cái cái lượng data mà đường dẫn cũng như
là cái conversation
ở trong cái 2.0 đó. Mình bực mình kinh
khủng luôn. Mình mình lôi lục mình lôi
mình lục mình lôi mình lục. Rốt cuộc thì
nó cho mình lại được một vài thông tin
thì một số nhưng mà có một số cái nó
không còn đường dẫn nó không hiểu được.
Đó thì nói như vậy thôi. Nó nó cũng có
những cái rủi ro mà mình phải backup sau
lưu trước mọi người ơi.
Ok [âm nhạc] rồi thì hy vọng là trong
buổi tối hôm nay đã có một cái phần nào
đó bổ ích cũng như là thú vị dành cho
anh chị em đã cố gắng ngồi với Minh
trong buổi tối hôm nay. Bây giờ cũng đã
9:52 và cái buổi zom này mình nghĩ là nó
cũng sắp đến giờ kết thúc rồi.
Anh anh Minh ơi cho mình thêm một khoảng
một phút nữa mình mình hỏi cái này nó nó
rộng hơn một chút xíu về cái về cái chủ
đề 2.0 hôm nay được không ạ? Dạ được anh
được anh.
>> Tại vì mình rất là thích cái cách anh
Minh chia sẻ về cái quá trình ai học và
áp dụng quên Minh thì thật ra là
[âm nhạc] mình cũng đang thử mình áp
dụng cho một cái nhóm nhỏ các
đồng nghiệp nhân viên của mình ở công ty
và một số bạn bè.
Nhưng mà khi mình bắt đầu mình mình lên
chương trình chia sẻ thì mình lại khi đó
đã có 2.0 nhưng mà mình vẫn dùng cái
[âm nhạc] ID cũ để mình chia sẻ và có
thể đó có vẻ như một cái sai lầm của
mình tại vì nhiều anh em vào thấy mở màn
hình đã thấy code nhảy tùm lum hết file
fix thì họ bị hoảng và họ nản thì liệu
anh Minh có thể tư vấn cho mình một cái
cách nào để mình [âm nhạc] cứu chưa cháy
lại bằng cách là mình nhảy thẳng qua cái
2.0 công này
có cho những cái lần tiếp theo mình chia
sẻ không?
>> À cái phần chủ đề này rất là hay nhá. Em
cũng đang thật ra em đang có một nhóm
chia sẻ như vừa rồi ở cho một cái
[âm nhạc] doanh nghiệp logistic và chuẩn
bị thứ hai tuần sau em cũng khai giảng
một cái nhóm [âm nhạc] khác cũng cũng
ứng dụng là em sẽ ứng dụng vào 2.0 thôi.
Nhưng mà quay trở lại với cái chủ đề của
anh Vũ á thì không biết là anh đã ứng
dụng là cho các bạn là đã được bao nhiêu
tuổi rồi anh?
Cái lộn trình của mình á thì lúc đầu là
mình mình không đánh giá được cái mặt
bằng của các bạn. như thế nào.
>> Cho nên mình mình hơi hôn đồm tức là
mình chủ tịch mình tính là hai buổi với
một cái scope nó hơi rộng tức là tổng
quan về AI và AI Asian.
>> Dạ.
>> Theo góc độ là chia sẻ thôi thì tổng
quan của AI thì mình tập trung nhiều ở
cái bản về mindset sử dụng AI, những
kiến thức tổng quan rồi những [âm nhạc]
cái skill skill cái kỹ năng sử dụng AI
đơn giản. Ví dụ cách prom như thế nào,
cái cách mình tương tác với AI như thế
[âm nhạc] nào và một vài cái mô hình
công cụ AI cơ bản. Tất nhiên thì từ th
để để mà xem [khịt mũi] được giống như
là lắp lắp những cái khoảng cách giữa
các bạn với nhau ở mức cơ bản. Sau đó
bắt đầu mình mới nhảy qua agent thì mình
cho các bạn thấy cái sự khác biệt giữa
chatbot truyền thống và agent như thế
nào. Bằng cách là mình đưa một vài cái
showcase mà mình đã làm một số cái
project nhỏ nhỏ ví dụ như các website
hoặc là một vài cái tool Python nhỏ nhỏ
để điều khiển màn hình này nọ các thứ
linh tinh thì các bạn thích. Có vẻ cũng
có một số bạn thấy thích nhưng mà mình
nghĩ [âm nhạc] cái chính á là một là các
bạn chưa thấy cái nhu cầu thật sự nó gắn
nó gắn xát với cái các bạn tại vì các
bạn chưa chủ động để đưa đưa đưa ra cái
bài toán của các bạn. [âm nhạc] Thứ hai
nữa là các bạn là toàn bộ là dân nên nên
code nên test nh
>> dạ.
>> Cho nên khi bắt đầu mình qua cái phần
thực hành thì mình mở cái cửa sổ anti
gravity lên đầu tiên thì các bạn đã thấy
code tùm lum hết. Mở cái file Explorer
ra thấy mấy file HTML thẻ tùm lum rồi
chạy thì à nó lại xổ ra là chạy câu lệnh
này câu lệnh kia cài cắm lum hết thì thì
bắt đầu các bạn loạn thì mình thấy chỗ
đó là là là cái cái có thể là cái sai
cách tiếp cận của mình mình đi mình đi
hơi hơi vội [âm nhạc] trong cái buổi cái
buổi thứ hai thì hôm qua thì mình có một
cái nhóm nhỏ mình đi từng bước một từ
cái cài đặt anti mình cũng có chia sẻ
cái cái cái [âm nhạc] clip của anh Minh
về cái hướng dẫn cài đặt mà bản cũ á thì
họ cũng cài được xong họ cũng vào mở
được lên rồi mình bắt đầu mình mới cho
tạo một cái project từ đầu tạo một
website thì tất nhiên nó bị vấn đề là
chạy nó lâu quá trọng phải cả gần nửa
tiếng tiếng thì nó mới ra được một cái
thành phẩm thì những người mà họ kiên
nhẫn họ ở lại cuối cùng thì họ mới họ
mới wow họ mới họ mới à ra
về cái đó nhưng mà những người khác họ
không có follow cái buổi đó thì họ vẫn
vẫn khá là hoang mang và bị giống như
kiểu bị bị bội thực bị ngợp về cái thông
tin [âm nhạc] sau sau hai buổi coi như
là hai buổi rưỡi của mình thì thì cũng
cũng có một hai bạn bạn cũng rất nhanh
bạn tự tìm hiểu s YouTube thì bạn mới
đặt vấn đề mình tại sao anh không giới
thiệu luôn cái 2.0
luôn cho mọi người thì mình nói là ok
mình cũng đang cũng đang tìm hiểu nhưng
mà mình như mình chia sẻ với mình mình
đợi nó ổn định thật sự thứ hai là mình
nghĩ vẫn phải có kết hợp với cái giống
như giống như hôm nay mình kết luận với
nhau là như vậy. Nếu mình mình bỏ qua
hoàn toàn cái đấy thì người ta chỉ biết
cái tầng Asian phía trên thì nó không
đúng cái ý của người ta thì cũng không
[âm nhạc] biết đường nào mà sử dụng. Thì
thì đến giờ này thì mình vẫn đang
concern là nếu mình có một cái bữa để
mình correct lại những người cũ hoặc là
mình làm cho một nhóm mới thì mình nên
tiếp cận như thế nào một vài [âm nhạc]
buổi đó thì là cái ngữ cảnh của mình là
như vậy thì
>> ok em hiểu rồi. Dạ ok. Ở cái góc nhìn
này thì em cũng chia sẻ thêm với anh
nhá. Anh anh anh đang có một cái chia sẻ
rất là hay. Cái case story này nó rất là
cụ thể. Đầu tiên là mình đi từ cái myset
[âm nhạc]
à mình đến skill set và cuối cùng đến là
tool set. Chắc là anh đang đi theo cái
hướng đó.
>> Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Dạ. Tuy nhiên á là nó có một cái
mà em đang tham dự rất là nhiều ờ
[âm nhạc] các khóa học kiểu kiểu như vậy
luôn. và các buổi zom thậm chí đến thời
điểm hiện tại của những cái đơn vị lớn à
những cái anh lớn có một điểm mà em đang
thấy nó cũng có một còn một cái sai lầm
đó là họ mặc định nhé cũng giống như
trong trường hợp hồi nãy của anh Vũ là
họ mặc định rằng cái công cụ antiravity
này hay là cái công cụ clot này thậm chí
khi vào cái là mọi người nói à mọi người
có công cụ đó chưa công cụ này phải trả
phí nha [âm nhạc] nhưng chưa hết nha mọi
người vào à mọi người tải cái skill này
đi, dùng cái workflow này, cách này để
tạo ra skill nè. Nhưng mà mình quay trở
lại là cái gì ạ? Mọi người còn chưa hình
dung skill là gì? Workflow là cái gì?
Nghe những cái từ mà thay vì là nếu mà
dịch từ tiếng Anh sang tiếng Việt á thì
à nghe thì nó à cái đó là kỹ năng thôi
mà, quy trình thôi mà. Nhưng mà rõ ràng
trong cái từ đó nó với ai nó không có
phải như vậy. Nó nó đang từ cái nghĩa nó
hiểu sâu hơn nữa. Như vậy thì lúc này
bắt đầu từ cái bài toán đó thì em lại đi
bắt đầu đi dần sang là hôm trước bắt đầu
[âm nhạc] em ngồi với một số bạn ấy nhá.
Và thậm chí em ngồi với một bạn hoàn
toàn mới trong cái cái gọi là A nhưng
[âm nhạc] bạn muốn tìm hiểu về A nhưng
bạn bị delay rất là nhiều. Bạn cũng tham
gia một số nơi, cuối cùng bạn hẹn em rồi
em ngồi em với bạn đúng 4 tiếng đồng hồ.
Đúng 4 tiếng nha. Đúng 4 tiếng. Nhưng em
vào là em đi từ cái cơ bản nhất luôn
[âm nhạc] là em nói em hỏi trước là bạn
đang bình thường dùng công cụ gì? Bạn
nói là bạn đang dùng công cụ là chat GBT
là thường xuyên nhất. Em nói vậy thì
[âm nhạc] đúng bài à anh sẽ giới thiệu
cho em một cái công cụ này về cái mặt
hình ảnh về cái cách sử dụng và cơ bản
đó gần như tương đồng với công cụ
[âm nhạc] chatbt thì em mới cho bạn
thấy. Rồi em nói về cái cách gõ câu lệnh
nè nó như thế này. Rồi cái conversation
nó như thế này. Vậy em thấy [âm nhạc]
nếu mà chuyển qua cái này em dùng được
không? Nói à dạ được. Nếu mà như vậy thì
cái này ok. Rồi em mới đi tiếp là như
vậy thì nếu như cách sử dụng bên kia là
em phải tải dữ liệu lên và dữ liệu đó là
những cái tập tin PDF hay là những dữ
liệu cần thiết thì [âm nhạc] hoặc là
Google Drive em muốn kèm em đưa vào. Vậy
thì bây giờ em đang có dữ liệu sẵn trên
máy tính. Trường hợp này [âm nhạc] em
chỉ thử lấy một tập tin thôi. Em để vào
trong một cái thư mục giúp anh và em thử
làm một cái cơ bản thôi. Thì tương tự
giống như bên kia em làm được không? Anh
chỉ [âm nhạc] cho em cách đơn giản vậy
trước mình mình làm việc. Thì như vậy
thì bắt đầu là em chỉ nói với bạn đó là
đi từ cái cơ bản nhất là em không làm
cái gì phức tạp hết. Em cứ đi trong 4
tiếng đồng hồ là bạn cứ gõ câu lệnh hỏi
bình thường cách bình thường bạn làm như
thế nào với chat GBT thì làm qua đây cho
em giống y [âm nhạc] như vậy bạn làm như
thế nào và cái nỗi đau của bạn đó là cái
gì? Ban nổi đau của bạn là gì? Em lánh
lý luôn cái nội đau đó. Bạn ứng dụng qua
bên này. Và [âm nhạc] cái tẹp dữ liệu
của bạn là hôm đó là bạn đang có một cái
bạn làm solo thì bạn đưa ra cái nội dung
chương trình là bạn đang kết hợp với một
bạn nữa. Bây giờ bạn muốn tổng hợp cái
đó lại nhưng mà đưa lên chatt thì nó vẫn
còn một vài cái [âm nhạc] khó khăn. Thì
em mới nói ok. Vậy thì bây giờ dữ liệu
có trên máy tính chưa? Em có rồi đó. Thì
vậy thì ok em cầm tay chỉ chuột cho bạn
đó luôn. Em vào
bấm giúp anh tạo ra một cái project thì
bên chat GPT nó cũng tạo project
[âm nhạc] được. Thì bên này cũng làm y
như vậy thôi. Tạo project chỉ đường dẫn
vào cái folder đó. Thì thay vì trên kia
là dữ liệu tạo project online thì ở đây
là project là một cái thư mục trên máy
tính vào đúng cái folder em đang làm
việc. Xong rồi em nói là hãy kiểm tra
giúp tôi cái dữ liệu có bên trong thư
mục này. Câu lệnh hoàn toàn cơ bản chẳng
có gì phức tạp. Sau đó tiếp tục là hỏi
tiếp là bây giờ là [âm nhạc] em đang
muốn cái gì? em đánh vào giùm anh cái
phần đó em phải là người đánh chứ không
phải anh đánh.
Rồi thì khi đó bạn mới
đánh cái nỗi đau của bạn ra nhập vào cái
mong muốn của bạn thì lúc đó bắt đầu nó
chạy ra một số cái yêu cầu và nó phát
sinh ra những cái dòng lệnh Python mà
giống như hồi nãy nói tại bắt đầu nó đi
phân tích từ một cái filew một cái file
PDF [âm nhạc]
thì lúc này bạn mới hỏi ủa cái này nó là
cái gì vậy anh? Sao tự nhiên nó hỏi như
thế này? Đó không sao hết. Đó là những
cái câu lệnh a lúc này em bắt đầu em mới
đi diễn giải thêm nhưng mà được một cái
là nó không có bị đầy màn hình giống như
giao diện của Google Anti Gravity
[âm nhạc] Ider đó. Nó chỉ hỏi mình thôi.
Và mình nói là đối với cái những cái
loại công cụ mới bây giờ nó sẽ giải
quyết cho em như cái [âm nhạc] này, cái
này cái này. Em tạm thời em chấp nhận
trước đi. Tạm thời chấp nhận trước.
khoan hỏi nó là cái gì để nó đọc được dữ
liệu đi. Sau khi nó đọc được rồi bây giờ
em mới hỏi tiếp là bây giờ em muốn làm
cái gì tiếp [âm nhạc] cứ làm rồi anh sẽ
hướng dẫn cho em. Và như vậy đến đoạn
bạn làm hoàn tất cái công việc ra bạn
build ra được cái sản phẩm đó và em nói
bây giờ em muốn ra một cái DASB không ra
một cái trang báo cáo tổng hợp cái đó
lại thành một cái DASB không cái DBO
dạng [âm nhạc] website luôn để là cho nó
nhìn nó trực quan thì bạn kêu vậy được
quá tốt. Thì bình thường [âm nhạc] em
làm bằng thế nào, bằng cách nào thì bạn
mới nói là bạn làm bằng cách A, cách B,
cách C bên kia. Em nói ok tại [âm nhạc]
đây mình vẫn đứng tại cái luồng này,
mình tiếp tục với nhau cùng cái luồng
này tiếp tục thì em đánh cho anh một câu
bình thường thôi là hãy tạo cho tôi cái
nội dung này
ra dạng gì đó vân vân. Chưa hết. Thì sau
khi xong hết cái đoạn đó nó ra được một
cái trang web [âm nhạc] rồi thì cái đó
là bạn tự làm. Bạn nói wow sao nó hay
vậy? À em mới nói là như vậy thì chốt
lại là nãy giờ em thấy nó đơn giản chưa?
có có khó [âm nhạc] khó khăn gì hay
không kêu ok em thấy cái này nó cũng có
không có cái gì phức tạp em mới nói vậy
thì bây giờ nếu như lần sau em gặp lại
tình huống này em [âm nhạc] phải làm sao
à từ cái tạo dasbot từ cái tạo này em
cảm thấy có mất thời gian lặp lại quy
trình cũ không vậy em có muốn tiết kiệm
thời gian để không tái diễn lại cái
trường hợp mà chúng ta gặp lại trường
hợp này ê phân tích cho tôi cái này rồi
nó chạy ra hàng lọt những cái cái màn
hình dọc dọc dọc dọc dọc gì đó bonh gì
đó thì em không có diện tả Đả với bạn đó
là B. Em nói đó là những cái phần ngôn
ngữ nó bắt buộc phải có nó sinh ra
[âm nhạc] để nó đi đọc được cái nội dung
đó. Em không cần quan tâm miễn sao cái
kết quả cuối cùng của tôi là cái gì,
[âm nhạc] cái mong muốn của tôi là cái
gì, còn lại cái kia nó kệ. Nhưng quay
lại [âm nhạc] cuối cùng là bây giờ mình
lại tiếp tục lần sau gặp lại trường hợp
này, gặp lại tình huống này thì sao?
Không lẽ bây giờ cũng ngồi chờ nó buill
lại từ đầu, làm lại từ đầu rồi lại cũng
đánh lại những cái câu A, câu B, câu C
rồi đánh lại tạo cho tôi cái LB boss. Ok
[âm nhạc] không? Như vậy thì em hỏi nó
luôn. Bây giờ đây là cái câu thông
thường giống như những người mới lần đầu
tiếp xúc với ai hoặc là gặp người mới.
Em có công việc này lần sau sẽ tái diễn
[âm nhạc] lại,
làm lại lặp đi lặp lại. Vậy có cách nào
cho tôi đóng gói lại cái thao tác
[âm nhạc] này để lần sau khi gặp tình
huống này thì ai chỉ việc là cái gì ạ?
Đưa vào là sử dụng được ngay hay không?
Đó. Câu đó tưởng chừng như đơn giản
nhưng mà [âm nhạc] anh thấy để cho bạn
tự hình dung ra bạn bắt đầu bạn ứng dụng
vào trong công việc của bạn luôn. Thì tự
nhiên khi bạn đánh xong cái câu đó nó
nói à đây [âm nhạc] chính là quy trình
tạo ra skill. Tôi sẽ đóng gói cho bạn
lại thành skill. Lần sau khi bạn gặp
trường hợp này, bạn chỉ cần gọi tên tôi
với tên A, tên B, tên C gì đấy là tôi sẽ
tự động lấy cái đó ra. Cái bạn mới hỏi
ủa [âm nhạc] à mình chỉ nói như vậy và
nó nói là skill. Vậy lúc này bạn mới
thắc mắc là skill là gì? Anh thấy không?
Lúc này, lúc này mình không app skill
[âm nhạc] cho họ mà mình đang nói ngược
lại để họ phải tự thắc mắc và họ đi hỏi.
Đó, họ phải là người tự cảm thấy là họ
đang có mong muốn, họ đang có nhu cầu đi
tìm hiểu. Mà tại sao mình chỉ nói như
vậy thôi mà đã hiểu bắt đầu nó tự đi
đóng gói. [âm nhạc] Mà đóng gói xong rồi
lần sau chỉ việc là gọi tên như vậy là
nó tự động ra lại cái quy trình mà nãy
giờ từ đầu đến đuôi
không cần phải lặp [âm nhạc] đi lặp lại
nữa. Và như vậy là xong. Và em nói đó là
một trong những cách đóng gói của
[âm nhạc] AI. Em chỉ cần nói với nó à
làm như thế thì nó sẽ ra được cái này.
Lần sau em gặp lại cái tình huống này,
em chỉ cần nó làm như này. Và nếu như
cần điều chỉnh bổ sung thì bắt [âm nhạc]
đầu em lại tương tác với nó. À tôi thấy
chỗ này chưa ổn nha. Chỗ này màu sắc
chưa ổn nha. Hay là chỗ [âm nhạc] cái
công đoạn này. Hãy cập nhật vào cái cái
cái cái mà sản phẩm mà bạn mới vừa build
ra. Em không hề đề cập đến cái nó em
không nói cái từ là workflow. Em không
đề cập đến skill và em cũng không cố
gắng để diễn tả là nó
phải chuẩn chỉ là phải skill phải mô tả
vậy nha nó mới đúng [âm nhạc] hay là
workflow phải mô tả vậy nó mới đúng cấu
trúc nó phải như thế này nó mới đúng
không với những người mới mình càng nói
họ càng rối. Theo kinh nghiệm của em sau
bao nhiêu lâu em ngồi tiếp xúc với rất
nhiều bạn rồi thì [âm nhạc] bây giờ mình
càng nói nhiều họ càng rối. Nên mọi thứ
hãy c để tự nhiên nhất vừa rồi mọi người
sẽ tự khám phá ra. Cho nên cách mà anh
quay trở lại cái bài toán của anh,
quay trở lại bài toán của anh thì hai
buổi thật ra em theo em thấy nó không là
quá nhiều, thậm chí ba buổi nó cũng
không là gì cả. [âm nhạc] Bây giờ mình
chỉ đi vào và mình nói là bây giờ cách
tiếp cận của anh á là cái công cụ mới nè
[âm nhạc] à nó sẽ có những cái phần
tương đồng với chat TPT. Thì thôi tụi em
cố gắng bây giờ mỗi một ngày thôi sử
dụng tí xíu thôi. Thay vì bây giờ chat
DVT tụi em một ngày sử dụng full time 8
tiếng với nó thì tụi em [âm nhạc] bây
giờ mỗi ngày chịu khó ứng dụng bên cái
công cụ Anti Gravity 2.0 này đi. À mỗi
ngày nửa tiếng thử giao việc cho nó đi
rồi lấy file lên bắt đầu làm. Vướng chỗ
nào hỏi anh à anh hướng dẫn. Rồi vậy
thôi. Có nghĩa là mình tạm thời mình
khoan áp vào cho họ một khối lượng cái
knowledge [âm nhạc]
ngay để họ cảm thấy bị ngập và mình để
cho họ tự tiếp xúc mỗi ngày giao đầu
việc cơ bản rồi rồi họ tự làm. Nhưng mà
họ vẫn mình vẫn cố gắng ép họ vào trong
một cung khổ là cố gắng làm sao là vẫn
phải dùng nó nha. Chứ không phải là ừ
mặc dù là nó là nó đơn giản nhưng mà họ
không dùng thì coi như cũng đổ sông đổ
biển thôi. Họ vẫn phải dùng. Đó thì đó
là cái cách cơ bản nhất. Thì kể từ cái
sau cái hôm mà [âm nhạc] em chia sẻ với
bạn đó thì bạn đó rất là wow và bạn đó
phải nói là thì ra tưởng AI A nó cái gì
nó cao siêu mà rốt cuộc anh Minh anảnh
nói cho em một buổi rồi là em về em giải
quyết các bài toán của em luôn và cứ thế
mỗi [âm nhạc] ngày em em đi dần lên bằng
cái chính cái công cụ 2.0 thôi.
Tại vì rõ ràng cái giao diện nó hoàn
toàn gần nhau gần tương đồng với chat
GPT mà.
Đó nó không có khác biệt lắm. Nó chỉ có
khác biệt là cái cách nó tự vận hành,
kết quả đầu ra là nó tự đi thực thi
thôi. Đó nên cách mà [âm nhạc] mình tiếp
cận thì như vậy thì em thấy nó sẽ làm
cho người mới dễ chịu hơn thay vì mình
cố gắng mình nhòi nhét cho họ một lượng
kiến thức quá lớn.
>> Rồi cảm ơn em rất là nhiều. Cái mình sẽ
thử rồi có gì chắc cũng sẽ nhờ mình chia
sẻ kinh.
>> Dạ. Ok anh. Em hy vọng là cái phần này
một phần thôi chứ còn lại tùy thuộc vào
cái tính chất công việc của bên anh
nhiều khi [âm nhạc] mỗi người sẽ có cách
áp dụng khác nhau nữa.
>> Có thể một phần là vì mình hơi tham cho
nên là một lúc cũng nhiều bạn tham gia
nên không có được cái kỹ thịch [âm nhạc]
như là cái cây của của anh Minh theo xát
một bạn được nên họ cũng sẽ khó thấy
được ngay cái sự [âm nhạc] chủ động từ
phía họ. Mà thựt ra thì cũng cũng họ
chưa gặp cái vấn đề mà mà phải xử lý cho
nên là cái tính chủ động họ chưa cao.
>> Họ cũng ngại là [âm nhạc][hắng giọng]
phải thử cái mới tại vì họ nói bây giờ
cái chatbot bình thường mà họ cũng đã
chưa chưa tận dụng được rồi.
>> Đúng rồi. Thật ra thì nó cái trường hợp
đó nhá thì lúc này á là nếu như anh làm
á thì thật ra ở đây á em đang làm một
cái quy trình khác [âm nhạc] à em đang
đóng gói ra thậm chí đến cái quy trình
dài hơi luôn là 12 tuần. 12 tuần, kéo
dài tặng 12 tuần. Và trong có 8 tuần đầu
á là em đi song hành với các bạn là bằng
những cái lý thuyết kèm với bài tập. Lý
thuyết kèm với bài tập nha. Có nghĩa là
mình đang cố để cho các bạn [âm nhạc] đi
từ cái cơ bản nhất, sơ đẳng nhất. Sau 8
tuần thì bắt đầu là bạn sẽ tự đưa những
cái case study, những cái nỗi đau thực
tế của các bạn vào và em sẽ là người
trực tiếp ngồi với các bạn để hướng dẫn
các bạn à xử lý những cái tình huống đó.
Còn trước đó thì em vẫn là cái gì ạ?
giao bài tập à và bài tập nó nhẹ nhàng
nha chứ không phải là từ lý thuyết đến
những cái bài tập. Ví dụ anh hình dung
nhé em làm cơ bản nhất luôn nè.
Antiamity nếu như anh nhìn vào cái bản
2.0 nó đã [âm nhạc] cơ bản rồi đúng
không?
Nó giống với chat TV nhưng mà em còn làm
cơ bản hơn